UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL COME TO ORDER NOW. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC PROTECT LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WILL MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING BAN
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE HI I
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT. THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
THEN WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORANGE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX TWO ONCE AGAIN THAT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX TWO.
AND THE ACCESS CODE. IS. TWO
THREE SEVEN ZERO EIGHT. ONE.
TWO THREE SEVEN ZERO EIGHT ONE
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SAINT
AND ORLANDO WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED. BY A MODERATOR TO
THE TO DIAL ONE BEEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR. TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THE TIME YOU WILL BE
A MUTED YOU ARE NOW READY TO-
YOU WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING. YOUR
YOU MUST READ THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON.
CERTAIN THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THURMOND DURING THIS
DIFFICULT PROCESS. I OR THE
DURING THESE DIFFICULT TIMES
ACTUALLY. I WILL MAIN I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING **** CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEDIAN SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS CONNECTED
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE EIGHT BILLS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY. WE WOULD LIKE TO
ADVISE EVERYONE DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS. SHOULD THE NEED
ARISE WE MAY LIMIT TESTIMONY TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR EACH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO A
BILL IN ORDER TO KEEP MEMBERS
AND STAFF HEALTHY AND SAFE.
BEFORE WE HEAR THE PRESENTATION
ON THE BILLS I'D LIKE TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM CONCERT
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WESSEL PRESS. HER WITH A
PRESENCE. BASED DOLLY. SENATE
ABOUT. THERE IS. HE'S HERE KERR
CENTER BAKER HERE. ELEVEN
THANKS FOR THE REPORT IS.
SENATOR PER. SENATOR DODD HERE
SENATOR DODD HERE. SENATOR
EGGMAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID
THE SENATOR EGGMAN HERE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ HERE SENATOR
GONZALEZ HERE. SENATOR GROW.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
MCGUIRE. SENATOR MAN YEAH.
SENATOR MEN HERE. SENATOR RUBIO
PRESIDENT SENATOR RUBIO PRESENT
SENATOR STERN. SENATOR BRADFORD.
SENATE BRADFORD HERE JERRY HAVE
CORN. OKAY VERY WELL WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL MOVE ON. TO THE
FIRST ITEM. WE WILL HEAR FROM
OUR FIRST AUTHOR OUR FIRST
AUTHOR IS ON BILL NUMBER S. B.
TWO H. AND WE HAVE WITH US
SENATOR CABALLERO CHIU- PRESENT
ON RURAL BROADBAND AND DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. VIDEO
COMPETITION REFORM ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SENDER
WELCOME PRESENT WHEN YOU READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
TWENTY EIGHT THE RURAL
BROADBAND AND DIDN'T COVER
REFORM ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AND ONE I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THE BILL. FIRST
THE BILL EXPANDS AND CODIFIES
INTO STATUTE ACTIONS THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM SAID PORT PORT
IN AN EXECUTIVE ORDER REGARDING
THE USE OF STATE PROPERTIES TO
EXPEDITE BROADCAST. BROADBAND
NETWORK DEVELOPMENT AND
DEPLOYMENT. SB TWENTY EIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
CALTRANS THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. OUR TASK TO
IDENTIFY SUITABLE STATE
PROPERTY. RIGHTS OF WAYS
WIRELESS SPECTRUM AND OTHER
ASSETS THAT CAN BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO EITHER PRIVATE OR
MUNICIPAL BROADCAST PROVIDERS.
THAT CAN EASILY BE LEAST
THROUGH BOILER PLATE LICENSE
AGREEMENTS. WHETHER IT'S THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISHING AND
WILDLIFE OFFICE IN MODOC COUNTY
OR A CALTRANS RIGHT AWAY THE
STATE CAN CONTRIBUTE THE
ASSETS. AND THE USE OF THOSE
ASSETS AND CREATE A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP TO MAKE
BROADER DEPLOYMENTS. FASTER AND
MORE AFFORDABLE. THIS IS
HAPPENING BY WILL TODAY IN MY
SENATE DISTRICT THE PATTERSON
SCHOOL DO WAS ABLE TO LAUNCH
DISTRICT WIFI BY LEVERAGING
THAT DISTINCT DISTRICTS
PROPERTY A SUITABLE LOCATIONS
DESPITE THE WIFI TOWERS. THE
STATE CAN MAKE IT EASIER. BOB
FOUR PATTERSON AND OTHER
PARTNERS SHIPPED WITHIN SB
TWENTY EIGHT. SECOND SB TWENTY
EIGHT AMENDS THE FIRST TIME A
STATUTE CALLED THE DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE VIDEO
COMPETITION ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIX OR DEBORAH. DEBORAH
PROVIDES CABLE AND TELECOMMUTE
COMMUNICATION COMPANIES WITH
THE STATEWIDE TEN YEARS LONG
FRANCHISE LICENSE TO DEPLOY
DIGITAL VIDEO SERVICES. SINCE
DIFFICULT PASSED THE DIGITAL
VIDEO PAY TV BUSINESS
ACCOMPLISHED COMPLETE MARKET
SATURATION MEANING PAY TV
SERVICES ARE AS UBIQUITOUS AS
ENERGY AND WATER UTILITIES.
NEARLY A COMMODITY AND THEIR
SCALE WHAT IS NOT CHANGED IS
THAT WHILE DIFFICULT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BRING COMPETITION
TO THE PAY TV MARKET IT DID
NOT. WELL DIFFICULT PROVIDES
THE CPUC WITH THE ABILITY TO
GRANT A STATEWIDE PAY TV
FRANCHISE LIGHT LICENSE. THAT
SAME NETWORK PATHWAY THAT FIRST
DELIVERED PAY TV TO CONSUMERS
NOW DELIVERS A BUNDLE OF
COMPLETE COMMITTEE CONSUMER
SERVICES MOST LOAD MODE MOST
NOTABLY BROADBAND. THE CURRENT
DIFFICULT FRANCHISEES OFTEN
DELIVER A PAY TV. BROADBAND
VOICE IP AND HOME SECURITY ALL
THROUGH THE SAME NETWORK.
CONSUMERS HAVE ONE CABLE THAT
COMES INTO THEIR HOME NOT FOR
SEPARATE NETWORKS ONE BILL THAT
COMES FROM THE FRANCHISEE NOT
FOR. IT'S A BUNDLE OF SERVICES
THAT CONSUMERS PAY FOR TOGETHER
ALL DELIVERED UNDER THE BENEFIT
OF THE SINGLE DIFFICULT. THIS
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE BUNDLE
IS NOT EQUAL ACROSS THE STATE.
JUST A HANDFUL OF THE TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT DIFFICULT
LICENSEES PROVIDE BROADBAND TO
APPROXIMATELY. 96% OF THE STATE.
S. TWENTY IS THE AND FOR TWO
MILLION CAL WITH BROAD. THAT
STILL PAY A DIFFICULT FRANK
FRANCHISE. FRANCHISEE FOR PAY
TV. ENTIRE COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS TO HIGH
SPEED BROADBAND IN ORDER TO
MAKE THEIR ESSENTIAL PURCHASES
ONLINE. WORK FROM HOME AS
REQUIRED BY THE SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDER ACCESS VIDEO
COMMUNICATIONS LIKE TO ZOOM. OR
EDUCATIONAL PLATFORMS LIKE
GOOGLE CLASSROOM SO THAT
CHILDREN AND COLLEGE STUDENTS
CAN ATTEND SCHOOL. THE
ABANDONED COMMUNITIES ARE IN
MANY CASES RURAL COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND ARE UNIFORMLY
UNSERVED OR UNDERSERVED BECAUSE
THEY ARE LOW INCOME LOW
POPULATION DENSITY OR BOTH. THE
PICTURE OF THE TWO YOUNG GIRLS
IN FRONT OF THE TACO BELL IN
ORDER TO ACCESS INTERNET FOR
SCHOOL IS ON HAUNTING PICTURE
FROM MY DISTRICT THE DRIVES
HOME THE STATE OF THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. SB TWENTY EIGHT REFORMS
DAVE DITKA REQUIRING DATA TO BE
REPORTED TO THE CPUC SO THAT
FINALLY THE STATE WILL HAVE AN
ACCURATE ACCOUNTING. OF WHICH
SUBSCRIBERS HAVE WHICH SERVICES
IN THE BUNDLE AND THE
CORRESPONDING PRICE POINTS.
GAINING THIS ACCURATE NEXT
NETWORK MAP IS CRITICAL FOR
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT THIS DATA
THE CPUC CANNOT READILY
DETERMINE IF A LICENSE SHOULD
BE RENEWED FOR AN ADDITIONAL
TERM OF TEN YEARS. AND RENEWING
FOR THAT LENGTHY PERIOD OF TIME
WITHOUT THIS DATA IS NOT IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST. SB TWENTY
EIGHT HAS A CLEAR INTENT.
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHOUT ANY PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE. CONSUMER
INFORMATION BEING SHARED. THE
BILL FIXES STRUCTURAL
INEQUITIES IN THE DIFFICULT
LICENSE GRANT THAT ALLOWED FOR
REDLINING OF SERVICES IN URBAN
AREAS AND UNDER INVESTMENT IN
IN RURAL AREAS IT DOES THIS BY
REQUIRING THE CPUC TO CONSULT
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITHIN THE FRANCHISEE'S SERVICE
TERRITORY REGARDING REMEDIES
FOR THE SERVICE IMPACTS AS PART
OF ANY PROCEEDING TO SUSPEND OR
REVOKE THE FRANCHISE AND IT IS
THE STICK THAT MATTERS MOST
BECAUSE PRIOR TO DIFFICULT.
FRANCHISE HOLDERS HAD TO
NEGOTIATE WITH EACH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO GAMING SUBSCRIBER
ACCESS- AND MISTER CHAIR YOU
MAY REMEMBER THOSE DAYS WHEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COULD
NEGOTIATE WITH WITH- THESE
PROVIDERS AND CONTROL A WHOLE
BUNCH OF- POINTS- IN TERMS OF
WHAT KIND OF SERVICES WOULD BE
PROVIDED GIVE COVER REMOVED
LOCAL CITIES AND COUNTIES FROM
THE TABLE AND SB TWENTY EIGHT
RESTORES LOCAL EMPOWERMENT
WITHOUT IMMEDIATELY SHIFTING
THE COST AND COMPLEXITY OF
NEGOTIATING THE FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS BACK TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. MY WITNESSES
SUPPORT IS KIMBERLY BALLOT AS
FROM TRANQUILITY A SMALL TOWN
AB FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE LOCATED
IN THE RURAL HEART MST TWELVE
KIMBERLY IS NOT AN EXPERT ON
BROADBAND NETWORK CONSTRUCTION
OR CABLE FRANCHISE LICENSING
HE'S HERE TO TELL YOU HOW RURAL
SMALL AND OFTEN POOR
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING LEFT
BEHIND LISTEN TO KIMBERLY'S
EXPERIENCE AND THEN ANSWER THE
SIMPLE QUESTION DOES YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY ON SB TWENTY EIGHT
LEVEL THE FIX PLAYING FIELD FOR
THE NEXT YEAR TEENAGER FROM
TRANQUILITY. THANK YOU AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU- SENATOR- I JUST WANT TO
INFORM THE PUBLIC- BECAUSE IT
WE HAVE QUITE A FEW PEOPLE
QUEUING UP. IN IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AT THE WE'RE GONNA
LIMIT TESTIMONY DUE TO- THE
COVERT RESTRICTIONS TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES PER SIDE. SO OF THE
SPEAKERS OF THE LEAST SPEAKERS-
KIMBERLY VALID DOES PLEASE AND-
CAROLYN MCINTYRE PLEASE.
CONSIDER THAT THE CLOCK IS A
CLOCK IS RUNNING SO TRY TO MAKE
MORE SALIENT POINTS IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. AS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO MORE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ARE ALLOWED TO STATE.
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WE
WILL NOW GO TO KIMBERLY HELLO
THIS. MODERATE IF YOU COULD.
PLEASE Q. KIMBERLY BELL OF THIS.
THANK YOU AT NOT THINK ON THE
PHONE LINE BUT IF YOU ARE A-
YOU CAN PUT STAR ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL YOUR LAW. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. BUT SHE'S NOT ON
WE WILL GO TO SPEAKERS AND
REALLY ANYONE YES HERE OKAY GO
AHEAD PLEASE OKAY KIMBERLY
PLEASE SPEAK. GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M NOT GOING KNOW IN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY OF THEM I LIVING CHEN
CREE QUE. I'M A CURRENT HOUSTON
AT HER NINE. IN EVERYTHING SHE
CREATE SCHOOL AND ONE HIS TEAM
BECAUSE ALUMNI. I'M HERE TODAY
TO SEE THE S. TWO EIGHT ZERO
BROAD IN STATE CAR REFORM
BETWEEN. TWENTY MANY OF YOU
HAVE HEARD AND WILL TODAY.
FIRST FACE A MAJOR VERY IN THE
AND- ONE HIGHLIGHTED BY THE IN
NINETEEN PAN. ACTION TO HIGH
SPEED INTERNET CONNECTION
ANSWER. AND RECENTLY I WAS ONE
OF THE- I THE DURANGO HIGH. THE
BY THE HIGH SCHOOL BUT I CANNOT
STAY THERE AS LONG AS I NEEDED.
AT HOME THE ONLY INTERNET
ACCESS I HAD WITH MY SMARTPHONE
MOBILE HOT SPOT. YET I FOUND
MYSELF WORKING DAILY PAST
MIDNIGHT WHEN THE CONNECTION
WAS THE MOST STABLE. SOMETIMES
EVEN GOING TO SLEEP AT THREE AM
TO WAKE UP LATER AT SIX OR SIX
THIRTY FOR SCHOOL. I NEVER
REALIZED IT WAS AN ISSUE I WAS
TOO PREOCCUPIED TO NOTICE
HOWEVER NOT I BEGAN MY COLLEGE
CAREER AT THE AGE OF SIXTEEN.
AND FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE AN
ACTIVE BY UNIVERSITY IN CENTRAL
NEW YORK. I KNOW THAT THIS IS
AN ISSUE EVERY WILL. STUDENTS
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO STATE. IN A
TIME WHEN I DAILY LIFE EVERY
MORE DANGEROUS. IN IT I IN THE
ONE THING THAT AB PERSON
ESPECIALLY STATE. OF COLOR.
SHOULD HAVE. WHERE WERE CAN
SUCCEED AND HE SAID. I DON'T TO
IMPOSE THESE HURDLES I'M ONLY
SELECTED FEW THIS. URGING ALL
TO PASS SB TWENTY. ANY OTHER
STATE KIND OF INTERFERE WORK
VEHICLE RESEARCH ARE PROVIDED.
TO ALL STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR
A PRETTY SPEAK. THANK YOUR MISS
FELLAS. OKAY WELL NOW A MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL- THE
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE Q.
A SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND I ASK THE WILL CALL ON
YOU TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME.
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL OF
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
HERE'S THE PART YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS CINDY
HILLARY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT PICKER. THANK YOU ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ERICA HOPPING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK MAYES BIGELOW LINE
OF NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS BANOS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU I WILL GO TO THE LINE OF
THE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JEFF NEAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
OF NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON ANDREA
BALL ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY EDUCATION COALITION AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO THE
LINE OF NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DANIEL REPAIRS ON
BEHALF OF TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE UP THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHOI
STERLING CARE AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
RURAL CAUCUS WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO
A LINE OF THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FOR HELLO LEARN THIS
IS SHOWN TO GET THE MCLAUGHLIN
FOR ACCESS HUMBLE IN EUREKA.
AND WE SUPPORT- SB TWENTY EIGHT
WITH REQUESTS FOR AMENDMENTS TO
SECURE. LOCALISM BY FURTHER
POWERING CITIES AND COUNTIES
AND CAN YOU SEE TO NEGOTIATE
AND ENFORCE LOCAL FRANCHISE
OBLIGATION. THANK YOU THEN
AGAIN FOR ALL THE SPEAKERS-
YOUR NAME FILIATION A POSITION
PLEASE LIMIT TO THAT. THANK YOU
OVER LINE ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU TO THE
ACTUAL DIDN'T DIRECT ANY
COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIRTY FOUR. JANE OF THAT OPEN
YEAH IT DOESN'T THANK YOU- THIS
PROBABLY GOVERNOR WIRE AMERICA-
WE NEED AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL
TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHETHER
THESE CONNECTIONS WILL BE BY
WIRE LINE OR BY WIRE LESS THERE
ARE HAZARDS FOR DOING IT ONLY
BY WIRE LEADS WE SHOULD BE PART
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO THEIR FOR
THEIR SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY WE OBSERVE THAT-
THERE ARE NO INDIVIDUALS HERE
IN THE GALLERY AND- EITHER TO
SPEAK OR IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION AND THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. SO WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE LEAD
OPPOSITION- TESTIMONY- THAT
WILL BE A PROVIDED BY CAROLYN
MCINTYRE AND THEN WE ARE
LIMITING THAT- CONDOS COMES TO
THREE MINUTES MISS MCINTYRE
EITHER. YES I'M HERE MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION APPRECIATES THE OUT
THERE'S A GOAL OF ENSURING THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGH SPEED INTERNET SERVICE BUT
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED SB
TWENTY EIGHT IT IS AN UNLAWFUL
EXPANSION OF THE STATE'S VIDEO
FRANCHISING AUTHORITY IT IS NOT
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD ACTUALLY
DETER INVESTMENT IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE STATE'S
FIFTY OF. ISSUE CABLE VIDEO
FRANCHISES IS DERIVED FROM
TITLE SIX. OKAY THAT THAT LAW
EXPRESSLY PROHIBITS FRANCHISING
AUTHORITY BLIGHTED PC FOR
REGULATING BROADBAND INTERNET
ACCESS SERVICE PROVIDED BY
CABLE OPERATORS. NOTHING IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS ACT GRANTS OF
STATUS ALREADY TO USE STATE
FRANCHISING TO REGULATE
BROADBAND SERVICE CLEARLY
STATED THE STATE IS PREEMPTED
BY FEDERAL LAW. SB TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD ALSO CREATE UNCERTAINTY
AND POTENTIAL DISRUPTION FOR
EXISTING SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
THEIR CUSTOMERS WHICH
ULTIMATELY BUT DID HER NOT
ADVANCE TO BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT. MORE SPECIFICALLY
SB TWENTY EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE
DIFFERENT FRANCHISEES TO DEPLOY
INFRASTRUCTURE CAPABLE OF
PROVIDING SERVICE AT THE
HOUSEHOLD LEVEL TO ALL
HOUSEHOLDS IN OFFENSIVE BLOCK.
NATION BLOC APPROACH CONFLICTS
WITHOUT GIVE CONSERVATIVE I
RECOMMEND IT TO THE P. 8% FILES
OF GEOGRAPHIC AREAS THAT DO NOT
ALIGN WITH HIM TO BLACKTOWN.
ADDITIONAL EIGHT AND FUND
CIRCUMSTANCES A COMPANY MAY NOT
PROVIDE SERVICE IN EVERY PART
OF A SENTENCE BLOCK WITHIN A
DIFFERENT FRANCHISE SERVICE THE
AREA. THERE ARE CASES WHERE
DEPLOYMENT OF FACILITIES TO
ENABLE SURVEYS HAVE BEEN ON
HOLD FOR MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS
DO YOU CAN A DELAY IN OBTAINING
NECESSARY PERMITS. AN ADVOCATE
DISABILITIES PASSED THROUGH A
FENCE IS BLOCKED IN ORDER TO
REACH AN ENTERPRISE CUSTOMER IN
ANOTHER AREA AND ARE NOT
ENGINEERED. TO PROVIDE
RESIDENTIAL SERVICE. SB TWO
EIGHT IS ALL NOT TECHNOLOGY. A
VARIETY OF BLOOD PROVIDERS
OFFER. CAL LIKE WHY ARE. THAT
OP WITH IDEA DIFFERENT. BETWEEN
EIGHT IMPOSE NEW MAY ONLY
DEXTER FRANCHISEES ESTABLISHING
DIFFERENTIAL REGULATORY
TREATMENT AMONG COMPETING
PROVIDERS THAT IS UNFAIR AND
WOULD ACT AS AN IMPEDIMENT TO
MARKET FORCES THAT HAVE
GENERATED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN BROADBAND NETWORK INVESTMENT
IN RECENT YEARS. THIRTY THREE
CC TA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES SB
TWENTY EIGHT AT THE NON LAWFUL
EXPANSION OF DEATH PASSED THAT
WOULD UNDERMINE THE STATE'S
GOAL TO EXPAND BROADBAND.
ACCESS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISS MCINTYRE OTHER
NO- SPEAKERS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERIA
REPORT AND ROOM TWELVE SOUL GO
DIRECTLY TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR PLEASE. Q. SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
THEY'RE ALL FAIR IN OPPOSITION.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
M. LIMITS THINKING ON BEHALF OF
MY CLIENT CONSOLIDATED
COMMUNICATIONS IN OPPOSITION
AND MISTER CHAIR MAN MAKE A
BRIEF STATEMENT. NO JUST PLEASE
STATE YOUR POSITION YOUR AND
YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN
YOUR PUT YOUR POSITION. ALL
RIGHT CONSOLIDATED IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MEXICO
MEDICAL BORDERLINE OF FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOURTEEN
AUBURN YES YES. THANK YOU FOR
OUR TOWN OUR CHOICE WE DO
OPPOSE THE BILL FOR THIS- ISSUE
BROUGHT UP BY TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRALITY AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE DOES HAVE A
PLATE FAIR PLAYING FIELD AND
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO NOT GIVE
EXTRA ADVANTAGES TO THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY WHICH IS THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF THE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACT BUT-
CERTAIN ALL YOUR INTENT PLEASE
STATE YOUR THOSE POINTS WERE
MADE SO JUST PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
AND YOUR POSITION. ON THE BILL
AND THAT'S FOR ALL THE SPEAKERS
PLEASE. CERTAINLY WE NEED
BETTER WHY WORK SO DRAW. THANKS
SPEAKER PLEASE. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY WILL COME NOW
TO- THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
DISCUSSION ANY MEMBERS. WISH TO
SPEAK ON THIS MEASURE. THAT AND
AGAIN- CENTER COUPLE YET I JUST
WANNA- I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITMENTS. OKAY YOU WANT TO
SPEAK- WE DIDN'T HEAR YOU SO
MAKE SURE THAT- CENTERS MIKE IS
ON WE'RE GOING TO GO FOR
SERVERS TO CENTER EGGMAN A
CENTER GROVE. AND THEN CENTER
RUBIO. THANK YOU MA'AM THANK
YOU SPENT A CAREER FOR WORKING
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT'S-
RELEVANT AND MY DISTRICT AS
WELL ONE OF THE ISSUES I HAVE
ADDRESSED SITTING ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND IN TWO HOUSES NOW
IS THE CONTINUED- ASSIGNMENT OF
MORE AND MORE THINGS TO THE-
PCCP YOU SEE. AND THEN WE BRING
THEM IN AND YELL AT THEM FOR
NOT. DOING ENOUGH AND YET WE
CONTINUE TO GIVE THE MORE CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT. IS THERE AN
IDEA OF EXPANSION OF THE OF
THEM RIGHT I KNOW YOU SAY THAT
YOU DON'T THINK THIS IS REALLY
GOING TO INCREASE THEIR
WORKLOAD IN WAYS AS WE KNOW
WE'RE JUST PASSING MORE THINGS
ON WHILE. COULD BE A LOT MORE
THINGS FOR THEM TO BE LOOKING
AT CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE PC AND THE IMPACT ON
THEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTION THE I. THIS THE
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL IS
LANGUAGE THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON VERY DILIGENTLY WITH THIS SI
PC. WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT MADE SENSE THAT THEY HAD THE
CAPABILITY THEY ARE ALREADY
REVIEWING LICENSEES ON A
REGULAR TEN TEN YEAR CYCLE
BASIS. THE PROBLEM IS THAT- THE
DATA THAT THEY'RE BEING GIVEN
IS REALLY INSUFFICIENT FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO- TAKE THE ACTION
TO DENY A LICENSE. BUT THE
FRANCHISE LICENSE- IT IS THIS
LIKELY TO GIVE THE MORE WORK I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY TRUE
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ASKING FOR MORE DATA WHICH
MEANS THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE REVIEWING MORE DATA-
AND THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO ALSO.
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- IN REGARDS TO HOW
THAT FRANCHISEE HAS DONE IN
THEIR PARTICULAR DISTRICTS
RIGHT NOW THEY HAVE. THERE'S NO
COMMUNICATION. YOU CAN MAKE A
COMPLAINT BUT THERE'S NO BASIS
UPON WHICH THEY CAN ASK FOR
MORE INFORMATION OR- OR DENY A
GIVEN THIS THE FRAMEWORK THAT
WE'VE WE'VE CONSTRUCTED SO. MY
GUESS IS THIS IS GOING TO BE
MORE WORK- AND DAD- IN THAT AND
THAT TELLS TO. WILL HAVE TO
LOOK AT THEIR BUDGET IN ORDER
TO MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT. THANK
YOU I WOULD JUST CONTINUE TO
CAUTION THIS COMMITTEE- THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE
AMOUNT WE'RE ASKING THEM TO DO
BEFORE WE BRING THEM IN AND ALL
OF THEM FOR NOT DOING THEIR JOB
ADEQUATELY. THANK YOU. CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
QUESTION AUTHOR IS THAT
POSSIBLE. YES I AM MEMBER
DOWNTURN QUESTIONS THANK YOU-
ARE YOU CONCERNED AT ALL ABOUT
THE C. P. UC'S EXPANSION OF
CABLE- OVER. THE CABLE
FRANCHISING AUTHORITY THAT IS
FEDERALLY PREEMPTED LIKE THE
NOW SUGGESTS THAT I HAVE SHOWS
THAT THIS CONFLICTS WITH
FEDERAL LAW. WELL I THINK- LET
ME JUST SAY THAT THAT WE HAVE A
VERY CAREFULLY CRAFTED THE
LANGUAGE. SO THAT WE AVOID ANY
FEDERAL PREEMPTION- AND- WE
THIS ACTUALLY IS VERY SIMILAR
TO LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED
IN THE STATE OF NEW YORK. AND
YOUR YOU HEARD- KIMBERLY
VALIDEA'S TALK ABOUT HOW SHE'S
GOING TO SCHOOL IN NEW YORK AND
SHE CAN ACCESS INTERNET ALMOST
ANYWHERE. IN NEW YORK STATE
THEY EVEN SET UP A STRUCTURE
FOR THEIR- THEIR ENTITY- TO-
ASK FOR THE SAME KIND OF
INFORMATION WE'RE ASKING FOR SO
I'M NOT CONCERNED ABOUT
PREEMPTION BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT WE VERY CAREFULLY CRAFTED
THIS SO THAT WE DON'T STEP. ON
TO THE TOES OF THE OF THE
FEDERAL PREEMPTION ON THIS WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS DATA WE'RE
NOT TELLING THEM WORK WE'RE NOT
TELLING THEM HOW MUCH THEY CAN
CHARGE- WHERE THERE'S A THERE'S
A WHOLE SERIES OF THINGS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PREAMPS
AND WE'RE NOT DOING ANY OF
THAT. WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
WE'RE BEING VERY CLEAR. ABOUT
HOW WHAT KIND OF DATA WE WANT.
HOW THEY DETERMINE. WHO GET
SERVICE AND WHO DOES NOT GET
SERVICE SO THAT WE CAN
DETERMINE WHETHER REDLINING IS
GOING ON AND WHETHER
COMMUNITIES POOR COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR ARE BEING EXCLUDED
BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY IT'S NOT
ECONOMICALLY- ED ADVANTAGEOUS
IN OTHER WORDS THAT THERE THAT
THE COMPANIES ARE ARE NOT
INCLUDING. COMMUNITIES THAT-
CAN AFFORD TO PAY THE HIGHER
RATES THAT THEY WANT TO BE ABLE
TO CHARGE AND SO WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS WE'VE ASKED FOR SOME
REAL SPECIFIC INFORMATION FROM
THE COMPANIES THAT WILL ALLOW
THE C. P. U. C. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THAT THAT'S IN FACT
HAPPENING AND IF THAT'S THE
CHARGE OF THE CPUC RIGHT NOW
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE GIVEN
THE CPUC THIS CHARGE BUT
WITHOUT ANY. ANY ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY GET THE DATA THAT THEY
NEED- IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION. THANK
YOU HAVE A ONE MORE QUESTION CC
TA HAS A- CONCERN THAT IT COULD
LIMIT INVESTMENT FOR BROADBAND.
I'M IN A LOT OF OUR RULES CAN
RULE COMMUNITIES DO YOU HAVE
THAT SAME CONCERNED AND IF YOU-
DO YOU ARE YOU ADDRESSING THAT
WITH THEM. COULD SPEAK INTO THE
MIKE OF SORRY ARE YOU
ADDRESSING THAT WITH THEM. SO
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH
EVERYONE AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT- THAT IS. THAT IS VERY
CLEAR IS THAT. IN ORDER TO PUT
IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE THIS IS
LIKE- ELECTRICITY BACK IN THE
DAY. THERE WERE WHOLE
COMMUNITIES IT DIDN'T RECEIVE
ELECTRICAL SERVICE BECAUSE THEY
WERE RURAL ISOLATED AND DIDN'T-
HAVE A LOT OF MONEY. AND WHAT
WHAT WE DID AS A COUNTRY'S WE
MADE A INVESTMENT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO CONNECT- PEOPLE
EVERYWHERE AND IN PARTICULAR
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVE
TO DO THE SAME THING. IN OUR IN
THE BROADBAND SECTOR AS WELL.
WHAT WE KNOW IT'S WE'RE GOING
TO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO- USE
OUR RESOURCES WHETHER THAT THE
CASF. WHETHER IT'S A FEDERAL
DOLLARS THAT- THAT THAT THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS IT MAY
BE APPROPRIATED. OR WHETHER
WE'RE USING- THE DOLLARS THAT
WE GET. IS IT PANDEMIC WHICH
CAN BE USED FOR BROADBAND AS
WELL WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
MAKE THE INVESTMENTS WE JUST
NEED TO HAVE THE DATA TO KNOW
WHERE THEY WERE THOSE
INVESTMENTS GOING TO BE AND CAN
WE INCREASE COMPETITION BECAUSE
THERE ARE A LOT. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF MOM AND POP. INTERNET
COMPANIES THAT WANT TO GET INTO-THE MARKET AND CAN'T BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THAT WE'VE STRUCTURED%
OUR OUR INTERNET- FRENCH I
SERVICES SO I THINK MORE
COMPETITION IS A GOOD THING.
BUT WE'RE ALSO GOING TO NEED TO
DEVELOP PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THE INTERNET
COMPANIES IN ORDER TO. TO GET
THE LAST REMAINING 2% OR TWO
MILLION PEOPLE THAT WE NED A
CONNECTED TO THE TO THE
INTERNET. THANK YOU. TERRAVIA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WILL
FIRST OF ALL I WANTED TO
KNOWLEDGE THE CONCERNS OF SOME
OF THE CALLERS AT THE
OPPOSITION AND I APPRECIATE
THAT- BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THE AUTHOR JUST
STATED THAT SHE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
AND I KNOW THA IT'S NEEDED I
KNOW RURAL COMMUNITIES FUNCTION
VERY DIFFERENTLY IF YOU COULD
PLEASE SPEAK INTO THE MIKE
BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING A HARD
TIME HEARING YOU SORRY. I SAID
I WANTED TO SIGNAL ITS THE
COMMENTS OF THE OPPOSITION AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
CONCERNS BUT I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE AUTHOR
STATED THAT SHE'S STILL WORKING
WITH US STAKEHOLDERS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO HI THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND I KNOW THAT
COMING FROM AN URBAN COMMUNITY
AYE YOU KNOW WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES AND
RURAL COMMUNITY SO I WANT TO
GIVE THE AUTHOR A OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD SELL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE TO
LOOKS UP THAT MOTION AND THE
MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS AND
REFER. TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
WHERE THE AMENDMENTS. TO THIS
BILL THAT THE- AUTHORS
ACCEPTED. WOULD BE WRITTEN.
INTO THE BILL DUE TO SOME TIME
CONSTRAINTS. SO- WE'LL ACCEPT
THAT OUR MOTION. AND IF THERE
ARE ANY MORE COMMENTS- CENTER
CALORIES YOU WANNA MAKE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I AM I
APPRECIATE ALL THE QUESTIONS-
NO TAT I. I WORKED VERY HARD
ON MY BILLS AND I AND I WORK
VERY HARD WITH THE OPPOSITION
I'D LIKE TO GET EVERYBODY ON
BOARD- THIS IS OBVIOUSLY- AND
ISSUE. OF EQUITY. WHEN YOU HAVE
PARTS OF OUR STATE A LARGE PART
OF OUR STATE. THAT DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GET. HI SPEED
INTERNET IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
DO BUSINESS IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO WORK FROM HOME IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO DO YOUR SCHOOL
STUDIES. IT IMPACTS THAT THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND THAT'S JUST
UNACCEPTABLE IN THE STATE- AS
PROGRESSIVE IN IS- AS TIED TO
THE INTERNET IS CALIFORNIANS SO
WITH ALL WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. VERY WELL WE WILL NOT
CALL THE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE-
CLICK PLEASE CALL. OF THE
MEMBERS. SB TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GOVERNMENTAL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS. WESSEL WESSELS I
DOLLY. ALL RIGHT WE WANTED
COURAGE MEMBERS TO PLEASE SPEAK
INTO THE MIKE ANYTIME YOU
SPEAKER VOTE PLEASE SPEAK INTO
THE MIKE. HI IT HAS TO BE ON
FOR I CAN SPEAK INTO IT. SENATE
ALLEY I BAKER BY SENATOR BAKER
I. FORGES ARE. CENTER PORCHES I.
BRADFORD. DOT HI SENATOR DODD
FIVE EIGHT MINS BY FIGMENT
NINE. DOLLARS I SHE'S YOU KNOW
GONZALEZ I HELLO I. FIVE
HERTZBERG. MCGUIRE MAN FIVE IN
I RUBIO HI RUBIO I TURN. SURE
THERE'S TEN AS- OKAY VERY WELL-
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF THE PROPS
OF MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT BILL THANK YOU I DON'T
NUMBER TWO S. B. FIVE THIRTY
SIX BY SENATOR WILK THE BILL
REAL RELATING TO
COMMUNICATIONS. AND THE- I FIND
UNIVERSAL SERVICE. PROGRAM
CENTER WILK WHEN YOU'RE READY
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS BEFORE YOU IS SB
FIVE FORTY SIX WHICH EXTENDS
THE AYE FOSTER PILOT PROGRAM IS
PART OF THE C. P. UC'S OUR
BROADER LIFELINE PROGRAM I WANT
TO FIRST TAKE THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL AND I'D ALSO LIKE
TO TAKE THIS TIME TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL
WHICH WILL PROVIDE INCREASED
FLEXIBILITY. FOR THE P. YOUSEE
TO PROVIDE THESE BENEFITS OF
FOSTER YOUTH IS PART OF THE
LIFELINE PROGRAM. MY 30% OF MY
DISTRICT RESIDES IN LA COUNTY
AND IT IS HOME TO ONE OUT OF
EVERY THREE FOSTER YOUTH. IN L.
A. COUNTY SO I'M WELL AWARE OF
THE CHALLENGES AND THE NEEDFOR
THIS PROGRAM TO CONTINUE. GIVEN
THE STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
CARE FOR ITS FOSTER YOUTH. AND
THE FACT THAT THIS PILOT
PROGRAM ENDS IN A FEW SHORT
MONTHS THE LEGISLATURE MUST
TAKE ACTION TO ENSURE THE
FOSTER YOUTH HAVE CONTINUED
ACCESS. TO THESE VALUABLE
RESOURCES WITH ME TOO TODAY ON
THE PHONE TO PROVIDE EXPERT
TESTIMONY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE PILOT PROGRAM
IS CERITA **** THE CEO AND CO
FOUNDER OF AYE FOSTER. THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM. THANK YOU THE
CENTER OF WE'RE GOING TO USE
THE SAME RULES ON THIS BILL AS
WELL LEVITIN. TESTIMONY BOTH
SIDES TO FIFTEEN MINUTES AND
WE'LL GO NOW TO. CERITA ****
SHE'S A LEAD SPEAKER IN IN
SUPPORT. AND IF WE CAN GET ON
THE PHONE. THE COCKTAIL AND
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
MY NAME IS THERESA **** AND AS
THE SENATOR MENTIONED I AM THE
CEO AND CO FOUNDER OF AYE
FOSTER AND A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH I TALKED TO THE NATIONAL
NONPROFIT PROVIDING OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
IN RESOURCES TO TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND FOSTER
YOUTH ANNUALLY ACROSS. ALL
FIFTY STATES. ACCESS TO
RELIABLE COMMUNICATIONS IS A
TRUE LIFELINE FOR OUR USE THIS
IS WHY I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT
THIS FIRST PROGRAM IN THE
COUNTRY TO PROVIDE EQUITABLE
LOW LIABLE COMMUNICATIONS. FOR
COST TO USE IS A SUCCESS.
PROVIDING A TOTAL OF THIRTEEN
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOSTER YOUTH WITH
ACCESS. LAUNCHED MEN'S MID
NOVEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN IN
JUST SIXTEEN MONTHS THE I.
PROCTOR PHONES FOR FOSTER YOUTH
LIFELINE PILOT HAS PROVIDED
COMMUNICATIONS. FOR ELEVEN
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
FOSTER YOU. MEETING THE NEEDS
OF THE 70% A PILOT ELIGIBLE
FOSTER YOUTH. WE CONNECT AN
ADDITIONAL TWO THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TALKS TO YOU
WHO ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THE
PILOT WITH FUNDING FROM CDSS
AND PHILANTHROPY. NOT ONLY DO
NEARLY FOURTEEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA FOSTER YOUTH NOW
HAVE RELIABLE COMMUNICATIONS
THEY'RE USING IT. PILOT
PARTICIPANTS USE THEIR PHONES
FOR COMMUNICATIONS WITH FRIENDS
FAMILY AND SUPPORT NETWORK FOR
SCHOOLWORK EMPLOYMENT IN
TELEHEALTH. 101% OF
PARTICIPANTS AND THEIR AGENCIES
BELIEVES THIS PROGRAM SHOULD BE
CONTINUED AND SHOULD BE
NATIONWIDE. WHICH IS WHY WE
NEED YOUR SUPPORT WELL THE CPUC
DOES HAVE PROOF CURFEW OVER
THIS PILOT DEFUSE ARE WARDS OF
THE STATE AND IT IS YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS SENATORS TO
ENSURE THEIR RIGHTS TO
COMMUNICATIONS ASCO TO FIGHT IN
THE CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE BILL
OF RIGHTS ARE REALIZED. THIS
PROGRAM IS THE ONLY PROGRAM
THAT FULFILLS THESE BRIGHT
INCLUSIVELY AND EQUITABLY YOUR
SUPPORT IS REQUIRED TO ENSURE
THIS PROGRAM CONTINUES WITH NO
SERVICE GAPS. WELL AND ALL
INDICATIONS ARE THAT THE CPUC
WILL RECOMMEND CONTINUATION IN
THERE ABOUT UA ATION REPORT WE
ARE SIX MONTHS AWAY FROM PILOT
AND WITH NO COMMITMENT NO PLAN
AND NO BUDGET FOR CONTINUATION.
FURTHER THERE IS NO PLAN FOR
SWAPPING OUT PHONES IF THIS
PILOT WAR TO CONTINUE. ON
JANUARY FIRST ALL PARTICIPANTS
PHONES WILL CEASE TO WORK
BECAUSE T. MOBILE IS SHUTTING
DOWN THE SPRINT NETWORK. THE
PHONES OF ALL THIRTEEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOSTER
USED AS WELL AS THE ESTIMATED
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED MORE WE
ANTICIPATE SIGNING UP. WILL
CEASE TO FUNCTION. FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE FALL CARE
TO. BONE SPUR FOSTER YOU. IN
WASHINGTON KENTUCKY AND
MISSISSIPPI TO REPLICATE THE
PROGRAM BASED ON THE IMPACT
ACHIEVED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT THERE IS A RISK THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA COST TO USE LOSE
THEIR COMMUNICATION GAINES. I'M
LOSING SERVICE CAN HAVE DIRE
CONSEQUENCES AS ONE YOUTH
PARTICIPANTS SHARE. I MIGHT
HAVE COMMITTED SUICIDE IF I
WASN'T ABLE TO REACH OUT TO MY
SUPPORT SYSTEM WITH MY I FOSTER
FROM. COULD BE THE REASON I
FOSTER IN OUR HUNDREDS OF
PARTNER ORGANIZED ASIANS
SUPPORT SB FIVE FORTY SIX AND
RESPECTIVELY. ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VERY WELL ARE THERE ANY
SPEAKERS HERE IN THE GALLERY
WHICH IS BEACON SUPPORT THERE
ARE NONE THERE ARE NONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES-
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. OF SB FIVE FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU AREN'T SUPPORT AT SB
FIVE FORTY SIX IN A PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. ONE ZERO BEFORE.
ONE MOMENT OF YOU FIGURING OUT.
RIGHT AND AGAIN IT IS ONE THEN
ZERO YOUR AND FLORIDA AT. FIVE
FOUR SIX. WHAT'S GOING ON. WE
WILL GET OVER THE LINE OF DUTY
ONE SEVENTY FOUR AIRLINERS OPEN.
MODERATOR FREAK PLEASE TAKE A
BREAK RIGHT SO TECHNICAL. WERE
HAVING A HARD TO. HEARING THIS.
SO WE'RE GONNA- WAIT A MINUTE
UNTIL WE- CHECK OUR SAYS HERE
IF YOU COULD JUST BEAR WITH ME.
MEMBERS OFTHE PUBLIC. WE'RE
HAVING SOME PROBLEMS HERE. AS
YOU CAN. WITH MULTIMEDIA
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMETHING.
MODERATOR GONNA TRY THE AGAIN
IF YOU COULD Q. THAN BAKER
WE'LL SEE SPEAK AN- THANK YOU
LINE SEVENTY FOUR LINE IS A-
SAN GREAT. SEVEN POINT. WE HEAR
YOU JUST FINE PLEASE SPEAK. MY
NAME IS JOHN HER NUMBER FORMER
BOSS NICE. THE YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT PICKERING ASKING.
NAME OF AND PUT THEM LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR- ON THIS
MEASURE THE MOTHER PLEASE
SECURE NEXT BIG. NINE SEVENTY
AIRLINE IS OPEN. FIND.
SEVENTEEN TO. THANK YOU CARE
GREENHOUSE ACROSS YOU. OR AT
FIVE FORTY SIX. THANK YOU
BIGELOW. WELCOME FROM NINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS- OPEN-
DELIVERY THE FROM ACROSS YOU
SUPPORT SENATOR. FIVE FORTY
SIX. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT THE
TIME NOGO TO SPEAKERS OPPOSITE-
ANY SPEAKERS- NINE AND IN THE
GALLERY NON IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
WE DON'T HAVE ORGAN LEE.
SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION SO
MODERATE WILL GO TO THE NEXT
BIG OF AN OPPOSITE. FOR IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO I COMMANDED ONE THAN.
CANALI NINETY EIGHT MY KIDS.
DANIEL GOOD ON OF TURNED UNIT
REFORM NETWORK WITHIN A UNLESS
POSITION BUT WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE
FOR TO ADDRESS CONCERNS. VERY
WELL ELSE. LINE NINETY FOUR
YEAR MIKE IS A. AND I APOLOGIZE-
THERE IT LINE NINETY FOUR WE
HAVE NO- FURTHER THAT TIME.
OKAY VERY WELL WILL COME BACK
TO THE OF THE COME. AND BE WE
HAVE- DISCUSSION HERE I JUST%
WANTED TO- ASK THE- SEVEN
PRESENTING A BOOK YOU OKAY THE
MEN I'M AT TOO MUCH YOU WERE I
YEAH I MEAN IN MY HOPE COMMON
AT JOHN DID I JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT IN CASE REYES MAKE MOST.
WE HAVE A QUESTIONS CA FOR THE-
AND IF NOT CAN WE ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. DID I HEAR- CENTER
BOARD JUST MOVES THE BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS AND AMENDMENTS ARE
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RIVER RE RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES. AND IF THERE ARE NO
MORE- COMMENTED YOU WANNA MAKE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB FIVE
FORTY SIX BY SENATOR WILK.
DEPRESSED AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
REAR FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES. WESSEL HI WESSEL I
DOLLY. DOLLY I BAKER BY BAKER I.
PORCHES HI FORTY I BRADFORD.
DON ALL RIGHT DODD I EGGMAN HI
FIGMENT I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ
I GROWTH I GROUP BY HERTZBERG.
MCGUIRE MEN'S FIVE MEN I RUBIO.
FIVE RUBIO BY STERN. THURSDAY'S
A VERY WELL WILL HOLD THE BILL
WILL HELP HOLD THE ROLE OF FOR
APPS MEMBERS BILL TO HAVE
ENOUGH VOTES ON THE IT WAS
CHAIR IN MY- THANK YOU WILL
CALL OUR NEXT AUTHOR. ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB SIX SIX TWO
FOUR CENTER ARCHULETA. THE BILL
REFERRING TO ENERGY
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. HYDROGEN
WELCOME SENATOR AND PLEASE-
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. HE
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN WITH SO I
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL SIX SIX TWO. SENATE BILL
SIX X. TWO VERY IMPORTANT BILL
HAND TAKES THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS ALLOWING UTILITY
INVESTMENT IN HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. AS MENTIONED
THIS BILL ALLOWS INVESTOR OWNED
GAS UTILITIES TO INVEST IN THE
DISTRIBUTION INFRASTRUCTURE OF
HYDROGEN TRANSPORTATION FUEL IN
ORDER TO ACCELERATE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE TRANSPORTATION.
BEFORE GOING ANY FURTHER I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND HIS COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED MEASUREMENTS ON PAGE
SIX OF THE ANALYSIS. AND COMMIT
TO WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS UP TO
WORK OUT ANY REMAINING ISSUES.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW BY GOVERNOR BROWN IT
MARKED A FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT. IN
HOW THE SENATE. AND THE STATE
WOULD INVEST IN ELECTRIFYING
OUR ROADS. AND FAX SENATE BILL
THREE FIFTY MANDATED THAT
ELECTRICAL INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES INVEST IN THE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
PLUG IN ELECTRIC VEHICLES
HOWEVER. NO PROGRAM EXIST FOR
INVESTMENT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES LIKE ALL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES USED
ELECTRICITY. TO POWER AN
ELECTRIC MOTOR. HOWEVER IN
CONTRAST OTHER ELECTRIC
VEHICLES FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES PRODUCE ELECTRICITY BY
USING A FUEL CELL POWERED BY
HYDROGEN RATHER THAN DRAWING
ELECTRICITY FROM ONLY A BATTERY.
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE STILL AN EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY. BUT FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY JOB GROW CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO FOCUS ON TWO MAIN
PRIORITIES BRINGING DOWN THE
PRICE OF HYDROGEN FUEL AND
MAKING HYDROGEN FUEL MORE
READILY AVAILABLE. THIS BILL
SENATE BILL SIX SIX TWO WHAT
DIRECTLY ACCOMPLISH THE SECOND
GOAL BY MAKING HYDROGEN MORE
READILY AVAILABLE. BY ALLOWING
GAS INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
BEGIN TO INVEST IN HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE WE CAN BEGIN TO
ELECTRIFY SECTORS THAT HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN HARD TO
ELECTRIFY FOR EXAMPLE BUS OR
TRUCK FLEET SUPPORT SHIPS AND
OTHER HEAVY DUTY SECTORS. SOME
CONCERNS WERE BROUGHT UP
HEADING INTO THIS COMMITTEE AND
I HAVE AGREED TO ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS RESOLVING THEIR
CONCERNS. AS MENTIONED. EARLIER
THESE CONCERNS ARE REP
REFERENCES PAYCHECKS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO MENTION THEM ONCE
AGAIN. IT MEMBERS ACCEPTED
TODAY WILL REMOVE HYDROGEN FROM
THE TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION DEFINITION
RELAX ANY MANDATES ON INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES AND MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS OPTIONAL. EVENT
COST SHIFTING SO ONLY PEOPLE OR
ENTITIES THAT WILL BENEFIT FROM
THE HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE
WOULD PAY FOR THE HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND FINALLY AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY PREVENT ANY
PROJECTS TO BE APPROVED THAT
WOULD CAUSE A NET INCREASE IN
EMISSIONS FROM THE ENERGY
SECTOR AT THE TURMAN BY THE
STATE AIR RESOURCES BOARD. AS
THESE AMENDMENTS WE BELIEVE
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS WE
BELIEVE WE HAVE ADDRESSED THE
MAJORITY OF THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS AT THE END OF THE DAY
ALL THIS BILL DOES IS ALLOW GAS
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
INVEST IN HYDROGEN DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE. IF IT WILL HAVE
A DIRECT BENEFIT TO THE
TAXPAYERS INVOLVED. THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN
FOR THESE REGIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL. I HAVEN'T KIMSA SEEN
BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE WESTERN
STATES HYDROGEN ALLIANCE AND
ROCKSTAND BAKER MADDIE.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
WESTERN STATES HYDROGEN
ALLIANCE BOTH ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND HELP
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND BEFORE WE PROCEED WITH
THE SPEAKERS I JUST WANNA
REMIND. THE SPEAKERS SO WE'RE
GOING TO PLAY THE SAME ROLE TO
THIS BILL THAT BOTH SIDES-
SUPPORT OPPOSITION. ARE LIMITED
TO. FIFTEEN MINUTES AND WE HAVE
TWO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL LEAD SPEAKERS WE HAVE JIM
SAYS SCENE. AND REC CENTER
BAKER MOHAMMADI WE'RE GONNA
START WITH TIM SAYS SEEN. THANK
CARE THAT YOU KNOW CAN YEAH
THANK YOU SO ARGUE FOR YOUR
TIRELESS WORK TO BRING THE-
PEOPLE OF OUR STATE. BUT I MEAN
IT CAN EVEN I'M HERE. THE STATE
THE LINE WE'RE HIRING GETTING
EQUIPMENT YOU'LL BACK SEEKING
TO ESTABLISH FAIR AND OPEN
MARKET FOR HIGH. ALTERNATIVE
FUELS SPANISH. INFORMATION LIKE
THAT APPLY EARLY BY AGENCIES.
AND YOUR EMPLOYMENT.
APPLICATIONS THAT HIGH.
EUROPEAN SERVICE AS BEING
YOUNGER MAGICALLY CALIFORNIA
CLEAN TRANSIT BOLEH HOWEVER
UNDER TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION THE REPAIRS
WOULD NOT BENEFIT. IT WAS MORE
EFFECTIVE GREAT EXPANSION WE
HAD NO CREDIT REPORTING HIGHER
G. CARBONITE WE EVEN THOUGH IF
IT WERE CHEAPER AND MORE
OPERATIONALLY EFFICIENT TO DO
SO. ADDITIONAL INTRIGUING STAND
SOON ALL TRANSPORTATION MUST BE
ELECTRIFIED AT ALL LIKE YOU'RE
BUYING CLOTHES MUST BE SERVED
BY THE BRIDGE AND THAT REPAIRS
MUST PAY THE ISLAND IS THE
BUILDING. OR STRUCTURE. THE
JUDGE IN THE CARPENTRY CARE
YOU'RE MAKING. OBSOLETE THE
SURVEY ALTERNATIVES AS FAST
WHERE THEY CAN BE BECAUSE-
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC. BREAK TRANSIT
TRANSPORT MORE EFFICIENT MORE
ALIVE. I MEAN SHE'S FREE SB
616 DEGREES MEASURE OF BALLOT
BY ALLOWING THAT. DISTRIBUTION
RATHER THAN BUILD WHERE IT IS
MORE EFFECTIVE RATE. BURGER
KING THE SUPPORT SIX SIXTY YOU.
TRANSPORTATION OPEN TO MODERN
DISTRIBUTED COMPETITIVE
ALTERNATE. PUTTING IT INTO A
CENTURY OLD CENTRAL I POWERS
THAT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION THIS REPORT SHE-
THANK YOU NOW WE WILL MOVE TO
ME BY MOHAMMED. GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE WHO WE FELL IN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TALKING
ABOUT THE HOMINY BY CONSECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LAST WEEK HI
CAROLINE. I THINK HERE WILL
ALLOW FOR THE GAP UNTIL IT
REACHES CARE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES APPROVAL BILL
HIGHER DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE CLEAR
THAT THAT DOES NOT MEAN FUELING
STATIONS FOR LARGE AND USERS
LIKE THE COURTS AIRPORTS
TRANSIT AGENCIES AND
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS THAT ARE
TRANSITIONING THEIR OWN
MISSION. BUT HAVE IDENTIFIED
HOW YOU FEEL BECAUSE OF THE
MOST SUITABLE HERE- MISSION
REPLACEMENT THE CURRENT METHOD
OF TRACKING INCREDIBLE BECOME
PROBLEMATIC LOGISTICALLY
FINANCIALLY. AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY. IT REALLY IS A
GREAT FOR A COURT ONE FEATURE
WAY THE NEED OUTWEIGHS THE
EIGHT HER CONTRACT READ THE
DATA. THERE ORACLE FOR POWERED
THE TRUCK THREE ON HAUL TRUCK
AND OTHER HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
AND EQUIPMENT. I THINK THIS IS
FOR YOUR HELP NEED BUSINESS OF
THE STRUCTURE FOR THE ON THE
SHOULD BE ALL ABOUT HOW THE- TO
REPLACE. EVOLVED FUEL AND JET
FUEL I THINK CENTER ARGUE
OCCURRED COMMITMENTS HE THINKS
IT'S HERE. AND BUYER BUT HE HAS
FOR PARITY WITH RESPECT TO YOUR.
MACHINE TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY NOW WE GO TO
SPEAKER. VINCE OF MY THEIR IN
THE GO NINE ROOM. OF MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE Q. A SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. OF SB. SIX SIX TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SIX
SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
BALI PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR
LINE.
IS ANYONE THERE ARE WE
WHAT ARE WE WAITING FOR. WE
HAVE ONE PERSON IN Q. ONE WE
ARE PROVIDING THEM WITH- LINE
NUMBER OKAY ONE MORE SECOND
THANK YOU. IN LINE FIFTY NINE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS TIM
CARMICHAEL WHICH OF THE
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU CENTER ARCHER
LETTER FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. AND MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. OKAY WILL WE DON'T HAVE A
LEVY SPEAKER NOT POSITION BUT
WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN-OPPOSITION. NONE ARE HERE IN
THE GALLERY OR NONE A ROOM
TWELVE SO WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN Q. Q. A SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SIX TWO
PLEASE. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. SIX SIX
TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. BACK COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. IN MY NINETY EIGHT YEAR
MIKE IS UP. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION- THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT DID NOT
FULLY ADDRESS ALL THE CONCERNS
THE TURN HOUSE WITH THE
LEGISLATION PROBABLY CAN WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OTHERS OFFICE MOVING FORWARD.
VERY WELL NEXT BIGGER. IN LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR MIKE IS OPEN.
I'M HERE VALERIE TRIAL OF OUR
HOSTS WITH THE CITY GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION WE
THINK THE AUTHOR AND THE MANY
FOR THE WORK ZERO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. WE ARE HEADING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION WE NEED A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO REVIEW
THE AMENDMENT AND OF COURSE
WE'LL CONTINUE OUR DIALOGUE
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE THANK. YOU THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. THE LINE
FIFTY. YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
MARK VENTURA GROUND AFTER
PROJECTED FINANCED BY NATURE
CLUB TO REGISTER OUR OPPOSITION
SB SIX SIX TWO. WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THE CONCERNS RAISED IN THE
CANADIAN VALASSIS ARE WE CANNOT
DEAL WITH A FULLY ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS- BUT WE DO APPRECIATE
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND-
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
HYDROGEN FUELED VEHICLES DRIVE
CAPAC AT THE MISSION
REDUCTIONS. BUT NOT JUST SIMPLY
AVOIDING EMISSION INCREASES
THANKS FOR TO THE AMENDMENTS.
WHEN THEY COME FORWARD THANK
YOU. FOR I YOU NEXT BAKER. AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
BRING IT DOWN TO THE COMMITTEE
THIRDS ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK
WITH THE BEGIN WITH CENTER
GROVE FOLLOWED BY CENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION.
THERE IS A CONCERN THAT THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WILL
INCREASE COST- CALIFORNIA
REPAIRS- DO YOU HAVE THAT SAME
CONCERN AND IF SO HOW ARE YOU
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND IS THAT WHEN WE
BEGIN THE NEXT LEVEL OF.
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT
CLEAN AIR INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO
ON- YES TO BE COSTS BUT AT THE
SAME TIME REMEMBER THIS IS ONLY
FOR THOSE WHO ARE GOING TO GO
IN THAT DIRECTION WITH THE WITH
THIS TYPE OF INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HYDROGEN. NOT A BLANKET OF FEET
AS WE DID WITH ELECTRICITY SO
IT'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
THIS GO ROUND BECAUSE WE
LEARNED THAT THE BEST WAY TO GO
FORWARD WITH ANYTHING LIKE THIS
IS TO ALWAYS GIVE. THE CONSUMER
THE OPTION AND THIS IS WHAT
DONE AND IF MY- SUPPORTERS
WOULD LIKE TO WEIGH IN ON THAT.
IF THERE'S ANYTHING THEY'D LIKE
TO ADD TO THAT. THEY'RE STILL
ON THE LINE YEAH- THANK YOU
SENATOR- WE HAVE SEEN FOR
TRANSIT AGENCIES SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS FOR HYBRID AND THE
STRUCTURED DIFFERENTLY WHERE
LARGE FLEETS ARE CONCERNED IF
YOU LOOK AT ELECTRIFICATION BUT
LOOKING AT THE OVERLAP OF BEING
BLACK OR TERMINAL OPERATORS
TRENDING IN THE. MARKETS ARE
COMPLETE ALL COMMENTS- HYDROGEN
THE MORE BRING COMMON TOGETHER
IN ONE PLACE THE CHEAPER BECOME
THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE. H. AND S.
ARE ACTUALLY SAYS. DISTRICTS
OPTIONS SET OVERALL THIRTY DAY
AND SHE THE OPTION THAT'S GOING
EFFECTIVE AND MORE EFFECTIVE
FOR RATE PAYERS GIVING THAT
OPTIONALITY CAN ONLY DECREASE
THE COST. OF GOING TO YOUR CAR.
THANK SIR. OKAY WE'LL GO TO OUR
CENTER GONZALEZ. S. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW WE JUST HAD
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY EARLIER
TODAY IN WHICH WE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT HYDROGEN AS WELL AND I
KNOW YOU'RE- YOU'RE VERY MUCH I
AM COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT
WE- INCLUDE THAT IN THE LARGE
PORTFOLIO OF OPTIONS FOR- OUR
EMISSIONS GOALS BUT I DO SHARE
THE CONCERN OF- SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION AS WELL IN TERMS OF
JUST. A NET INCREASE- THE
RESULTS IN THE NEXT INCREASE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SEE
REDUCTIONS BEING MADE
ESPECIALLY NEAR OUR PORTS IN
WHICH I REPRESENT TO ME WITH
THERE'S A LOT- OF EMISSIONS AS
WE KNOW IN AND AROUND OUR PORTS
THROUGH OUR COMMUNITIES AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE LIKE TO SEE
THAT HAVE THAT SORT OF
HYDROGEN. IT REALLY WORKS AT
REDUCING- VERSES JUST RESULTING
IN A NET INCREASE SO WITH
THAT'LL SUPPORT THIS TODAY BUT
WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH YOU AS WELL AS CHURCH
TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU
SENATOR IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR
POINT OUT THAT ONE OF THE ITEMS
THAT I MENTIONED IS BRINGING
DOWN THE PRICE OF HYDROGEN.
MAKING SURE THAT HYDROGEN IS IT
MORE READILY AVAILABLE AND
ALLOWING US TO GO FORWARD IN
CALIFORNIA TO SET THE STAGE
ACROSS THE NATION FOR SENATORS
ARE YOU'LL HAVE YOU'LL HAVE A
CHANCE TO CLOSE TO MAYBE YOU%
CAN MAKE THOSE TO YOUR CLOSING
STATEMENTS BUT FIRST I WANTED
TO GET A MOTION. ON THE RECORD
AND- YOU DID MENTION THAT YOU
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS YES SIR
AND THAT WERE ASKING IN A
BEDROOM A MOTION BE MADE AS TO
DO PASS UP AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY IF WE CAN HAVE THAT
CENTER BACK REALLY PUSH IT THAT
VERY AHEAD OF WHAT DID YOU WANT
TO MAKE THAT OR DID YOU WANT TO
SPEAK BUT WHEN HE SPEAKS ARE.
OKAY DID WE HAVE ANY ALL I WANT
I ALSO WANT TO SPEAK. OFTEN ON.
OKAY SO SOON AS WE SPEAK- TO.
WANNA MAKE THAT MOTION. OKAY
WILL COME. AFTER CENTER BACK
BACK SPEAKS BAKER. GREAT I
TWENTY I THE AUTHOR'S CHANGE
CLARIFY THAT THE- CAUSES
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE CANNOT-BE COLLECTED FROM THE RETAIL
NATURAL GAS CUSTOMERS AND OTHER
ENSURE ASSURANCES THAT THE- BIG
THE INTENT OF THE HUNDRED OF
ESTIMATES SUPPORT. TRUCKING AND
OTHER HEAVY DUTY
TRANSPORTATION- REALLY THAT'S
IN N MY MIND THE BEST
APPLICATION- RATHER THAN TRYING
TO BUILD. PACWEST EVERY GAS
STATION AND IN CALIFORNIA- I AM
JUST WANTED TO COMMENT AGAIN ON
THE HYDROGEN ITSELF IF WE ARE
GOING TO SUPPORT. THE BILL OUT
OF HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES. THERE
WAS ALSO MAKE SURE THE
HYGIENIST SELF WHAT WILL LOWER
EMISSIONS SO. A PLAN TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY A TO HELP MOVE
FORWARD BUT WANT TO RAISE THESE
CONCERNS I LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND SO WE
WILL ACCEPT THE MOTION NOW FROM
SENATOR MEN. THANK YOU AND- I
JUST WANTED MY OWN LITTLE
COMMENTS IN TERMS OF THE
DISCUSSION IT WAS REYES BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S A- IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INFORM SO. ABOUT
THIS BILL. THERE YOU KNOW
THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF
LEGISLATION THAT WE PASSED OVER
THE YEARS THAT ALLOWED BECAUSE
SHIPS ARE RATE PAYERS.
PROFESSIONALLY ELECTRIFY
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE GRID AND
SOLAR THERE BUT NOT A CONSCIOUS
SAID ABOUT PASSED ON TO REACH
RATEPAYERS. THIS BILL IS NOT
ONE OF THEM THIS BILL WE ADDED
AMENDMENT THE- AUTHOR ACCEPTED
A BILL. THAT WOULD PREVENT A
COST SHIPS IRWIN- THE A BILL
THE SUPPLIED ANOTHER THING
RELATED TO HYDROGEN. DO YOU
KNOW HOW COMING UP WITH A
COMPETITOR POLICY YEAR HERE
CALIFORNIA TO SPUR HYDROGEN
WOULD MEAN WE'D SEE MORE
INVESTMENT DOLLARS COMING INTO
OUR STATE TO SPUR THE THESE
JOBS SO THIS IS. A NET POSITIVE
THE GAIN OF FIVE DOLLARS COMING
INTO OUR CALIFORNIA ECONOMY TO
MAKE- HYDROGEN THE COMPETITIVE
AND THERE IS ALREADY PLENTY
PLENTY OF ANALYSIS THAT THE-
THAT SHOWS THAT ONCE A HYDROGEN
STARTS EXPAND THE PROP THE- THE
COST OF HYDROGENS CODE IT'S
GOING TO GO DOWN IN THE FUTURE.
AND SAVE RATEPAYERS MONEY IN
COMPARISON TO OTHER-
COMPETITIVE- OF GREEN ENERGY SO
THIS THIS WILL BE A AN INDUSTRY
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY OUT
COMPETE ALMOST ANY OTHER GREEN
ENERGY SO THIS IS SOMETHING.
WORTH LOOKING OUT FOR A REPAIR
SIX AND THE THEIR FUTURE TO
POCKET CLEANER FUEL AT A
CHEAPER PRICE SO- I WANNA THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING FORWARD
TO SPILL IN TAKING THIS ON AS A
CHALLENGE. THAT AND HIS GOOD
WORK ON THIS BILL IN ITS
ABILITY WORK VERY WELL WITH OUR
STAFF I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH OF CENTER TO LETTER
DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS OF MATURITY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND WE ARE
READY TO CLOSE AND I THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY.
MUCH OF PUT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. S. SIX SIXTY SENATOR TO
LET THEM DO PASSED AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. WESA
FIVE WESSEL HI DOLLY NO. DOLLY
KNOWN RECORD. FIVE BAKER HI
REGIS. BRADFORD ALL RIGHT. MARK
BRADFORD HI. DODD I STARTED BY
EGGMAN ALL RIGHT. EGGMAN HI
GONZALEZ HI. GONZALEZ I. GROVE.
HERTZBERG NO. I'M SORRY CENTER
GROW GROW WAS A NO. NO
HERTZBERG. MCGUIRE. MAN HI MAN
I. RUBIO HI RUBIO I STERN. AS
AND THREE TO KNOWS OKAY WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL THANK YOU CENTER
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS- THAT WILL PRESENT FROM
HER DESK CENTER GONZALEZ HONEST
BEFORE- RELATED TO THE
COMMUNICATIONS CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND. CENTER
GONZALEZ BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON- BEFORE
I BEGIN I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
ON PAGES SEVEN THROUGH EIGHT OF
THE ANALYSIS THESE AMENDMENTS
TO THE FOLLOWING THE UPGRADE
BUILD UP SPEED REQUIREMENTS
FROM TWENTY FIVE THREE TO ONE
HUNDRED DOWN TWENTY UP THANK
YOU AT A YEARLY CAP ON THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT CAN BE
COLLECTED AT ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION AND ADD A SUNSET DATE
OF TEN YEARS REMOVED
SECURITIZATION ADJUSTS THE HIGH
POVERTY DEFINITION. AND ADDS
FAIR GROUNDS AS AN ELIGIBLE
ENTITY FOR THESE GRANTS AS WE
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF-
EMERGENCIES WERE FOR
FAIRGROUNDS OF NEEDED- THIS
SERVICE I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB
FOUR WHICH IS A CRITICAL
MEASURE TO HELP CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE BOTH DURING AND
AFTER THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AS WE ALL KNOW
ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BROADBAND
COUNCIL 23% OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING UNITS HOME TO EIGHT
POINT FOUR MILLION RESIDENTS
DON'T HAVE A BROADBAND
SUBSCRIPTION THE REPORT
ADDITIONALLY FOUND THAT ROUGHLY
SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS LACK HIGH
SPEED BROADBAND WITH THREE
HUNDRED FIVE THOUSAND RESIDING
IN URBAN AREAS ACROSS THE STATE
WERE SEE EXAMPLES OF HOW THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IS PREVENTING
CALIFORNIANS FROM ENGAGING IN
CRITICAL DIGITAL ACTIVITIES.
WHETHER IT IS GOING TO HAVE
STUDENTS GO TO A TACO BELL AS
WE'VE SEEN WITH SENATOR KENNEDY
I DON'T HAVE I GET AWAY SHE
MENTIONED THEY WERE DOING THEIR
HOMEWORK THROUGH WIFI ACCESS AT
TACO BELL IN SALINAS OR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS WHO DO NOT HAVE
FAST ENOUGH INTERNET TO RECEIVE
TELEHEALTH SERVICES FAMILIES
SMALL BUSINESSES WE'VE SEEN IT
ALL THIS BILL REDEFINED THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND TO ENABLE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS TO BE BUILT IN
UNSERVED AREAS. THE CHANGE WILL
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS. OF
ALL SIZES TO APPLY FOR GRANTS
IN A- INTO PERCENT. INTERNET
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN MEET
CALIFORNIANS FUTURE NEEDS.
IT'LL STABILIZE THE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THE ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND BY EXTENDING THE
SUNSET ON THE SURCHARGE FOR
MORE THAN TEN YEARS WILE
ALLOWING ROUGHLY ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
THREE REIMAGINE FEET
ASSESSMENT. ON ALL ACCESS LINES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS IS A
SIMILAR FORMULA TOWARDS THE
STING NINE ONE ONE SURCHARGE
THIS CHANGE WILL ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S ONLY SOURCE OF.
FUNDING FOR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE DOES NOT
DISAPPEAR. THIS IS A SUPPORTED
BY A DIVERSE COALITION OF OVER
ONE HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS.
INCLUDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
BOTH URBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES EDUCATION ADVOCATES
LABOR LEADERS SMALL INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND MANY
MORE. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY HAVE ERNESTO FUND COHEN.
SENIOR LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL AT
THE L. A. AT THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION. AND TRACY
RAIMES LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE RULE
COUNTIES REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK THEM BOTH
FOR BEING HERE. AND MISTER
CHAIR RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON. SB FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I JUST WANT TO INFORM
THE PUBLIC- THAT IS LISTENING
INTO. INTOOUR- TRANSMISSION
HERE. THAT WE ARE GOING TO
OBSERVE THE FIFTEEN MINUTE RULE
FOR BOTH SIDES. IN FAVOR AND
IN. SUPPORT FIFTEEN AND
FIFTEEN. AND WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION OF THE SPEAKERS
AND SUPPORT BEGINNING WITH. A
NEST OF FATHER COHEN. IF HE IS
ON THE PHONE PLEASE SPEAK NOW.
HI DEAR ME YES WE HEAR YOU FIND.
ACTUALLY FIVE CHARLIE SERVICER
DOLLY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAMES ARE NOT THE
PHONE I AM THAT SEAMLESS OF
COUNSEL FOR THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION ALSO KNOWN
AS THE AT BAT. MY RESEARCH FOR
THIS ORGANIZATION HAS FOCUSED
ON HOW WE BUILD TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY READY BROADBAND ACCESS
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY. HOW WE
AVOID MAKING THE MISTAKES OF
THE PAST THAT HAVE GIVEN US THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE UP TODAY. AND I
DAY DOES MY BOYS COMMITTEE
BEFORE FIBER IS THE FOUNDATION
OF ALL FUTURE READY BROADBAND
ACCESS WHETHER WIRELESS OR
WIRED WITHOUT EXCEPTION. SB
FOUR MAKES IMPORTANT PROGRESS
TOWARDS PUSHING FIBER
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH TWO CORE
PROGRAMS- BOND PROGRAM FOR
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
UPDATED GRANT PROGRAM. I AM
PROGRAMS CHANGES REFLECTS
GOVERNOR NEWSOM EXECUTIVE ORDER
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT ALLOWS
THE CPT TO ADJUST THE PROGRAM
TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL DOLLARS
SHOULD CONGRESS PASS PRESIDENT
BIDEN ROBIN PLAN. TO BUILD
FUTURE PROOF FIBRE
INFRASTRUCTURE ALL AMERICANS.
THE BILL'S BOND FINANCING
PROGRAM WOULD ENABLE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS BY THE
PUBLIC SECTOR IN DELIVERING
FIBRE INFRASTRUCTURE IN RURAL
MARKET AND LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING OF IT THAT
THERE'S A SHARE A STRONG
COMMITMENT BY THE GOVERNOR AND
LEADERSHIP TO CREATE THE PUBLIC
MODEL SOON. SO FOR NOW THE
PROVISIONS BEING HER MOVEMENTS
BEFORE TO BE INCORPORATED IN A
LATER DATE. I HAVE BUT I CAN
SAY WITH ABSOLUTE CERTAINTY
THAT WE CAN'T DELIVER TOWARD
UNIVERSAL TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
BY READY ACCESS BUT WE DO NOT
INCLUDE- PUBLIC MODEL. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IN CONCLUSION I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR LENA
GONZALEZ FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
THIS SPACE PROVISION FOR THE
STATE NOW SHARED BY THE
PRESIDENT UNITED STATES FOR THE
NATION. AND HOW WE WILL END THE
DESERVE A BY PARK CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE WILL MOVE IT OUT TO
CHURCH TRACY RYAN. HE'S ON THE
ON THE LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI TRACY
RIGHT WITH THE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA I DON'T THINK WE
NEED TO DELIVER THE VERY
CURRENT ISSUES WE HAVE WITH THE
LACK OF RELIABLE MEMBERS BY THE
END AND THEN HE ENTERED THE
CALIFORNIA FROM SCHOOL KIDS
TRYING TO FIND WIFI TO COMPLETE
THEIR HOMEWORK HERE TO STRUGGLE
FOR ALL RESIDENTS HAVE ACCESS
TO TELEMEDICINE OPTION FOR
HEALTHCARE. PROVIDERS AND WELL
DOCUMENTED THIS YEAR AT THE
CORE REPRESENTS A LARGE STAFF
INCLUDING KILL MORE ALCOHOL
BROADBAND BECAUSE HE IN
CALIFORNIA BY MAKING MANY VERY
IMPORTANT CHANGER. ONE THAT I
WANT TO DO IS THE UPDATING OF
THE CONNECTION FEE CORRECT HOLD.
FOR ONE CONSIDERED UNDER
SPONSORED. A VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE CURRENT CAPITA. OF
ON THIRD STREET A GROUP OF
BIRTH THAT WERE THIRD.
DOWNSTREAM AND ONE OF THREE.
WILL LIKELY NEVER. HAVE A
SERVICE UPGRADE EVEN THE
CURRENT FEDERAL. OF FIVE.
SECONDS AT THE CORE OF THE
SIZES FIBER DEPLOYMENT AGAIN.
MATTERS ARE FAR TOO LONG WELL
AREAS HAVE BEEN TOLD SOMETHING
IS BETTER THAN NOTHING. HOWEVER
IF SOMEONE THAT HAS THAT
SOMETHING WOULD BE CORRECTED
SIX ONE. THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY
IS NOT RELIABLE ADEQUATE ENOUGH
FOR. FOR EVERYDAY TASKS SUCH AS
HOMEWORK. CERTAINLY NOT THAT'S
NOT THE WORKING FROM HOME. IT'S
TIME THAT WE REQUIRE THE STATE
SUBSIDIZED BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROVIDE FUTURE
PROOF TECHNOLOGY. NOT ONLY TO
ALLOW RESIDENTS EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. TO USE
TELEMEDICINE DISTANCE LEARNING
AND HAVE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
BUT AS A FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE.
USE OF PUBLIC FUNDS. SHE TENER
INVOLVED WITH A TO MAKE
BROADBAND TO PRIORITY WE WERE
SO ASK FOR YOUR I. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NO WILL GO TO. IN%
SUPPORT FROM THE GENERAL A
PHONE LINE THERE'S NO ONE HERE
IN THE GALLERY NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE- ROOMONE TWELVE.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF US
BEFORE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
IN LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR MIKE IS A- GOOD
AFTERNOON BUT NOTHING ABOUT THE
TRIP STRATEGY BUNDY HAPPENS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT BAKER. LINE EIGHTY
SIX YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU RYAN SPENCER ON BEHALF OF
YOUR CLIENT KIBBLE P. AMERICA
AND OKAY BOTH IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANKS BAKER. THE LINE AT
ONE HUNDRED THIRTEEN YEAR MIKE
IS A. KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION ON BEHALF BY CLASSIFIED
WORKERS THAT ARE ODD BOARDMAN
BRIDGING THE EQUITY GAP
MEETINGS OF THE ESSENTIAL PART
BECAUSE SPONSORS. NEXT BECAUSE.
LINE EIGHTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS UP.
IN THE HILLARY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANKS BAKER. LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE YOUR
MIKE ITSELF. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TOLD ME AT THE
LEASH ON BEHALF OF OVER TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
A CO SPONSOR AND IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANKS SPEAKER. LINE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON RUN
AWAY WITH ELECTIONS AND I'M ON
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. NEXT
BECAUSE- LINE EIGHTY THREE YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. WHY EIGHTY THREE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE. WELL I IN ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE
IS A. KAREN NUMBER ACTUALLY
WALKER WOULD NOT PLAN ON BEHALF
OF THE MONTEREY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. NEXT
BIGGER. BLIND TWELVE YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MARVIN BEYOND WITH COMMON SENSE
MEDIA IN STRONG SUPPORTER BEST
BEFORE. NEXT BECAUSE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO YOUR MIKE
ITSELF. THANK YOU GOOD EVENING
GHANA COLIN WITH POWERFUL BURKE
ON AMERICA AND READY NATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. THANK RUN
IT COULD BE A LITTLE CREWS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FLORIDA ACTION FUND AND THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC SUMMIT OR
DEPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
FORTY YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. ARE
NOT AVAILABLE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA X. COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
LINE NINETY FIVE YOUR MIKE AT
THE. WELL I NINETY FIVE YOUR
MIKE AT THE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
NINETEEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
THIS IS YOUR HEARING YES- I
REPRESENT OR ANY- PRE. WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT BIGGER. BLIND
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE YOUR MY
KIDS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
ARE TRAVIS GOING TO INSTITUTE
FOR QUALITY EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HELLO
JOHN MEMBERS CAROLINE TRENTINI
ON BEHALF OF ONLY A CALIFORNIA
CITY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER.
BLIND ONE HUNDRED THIRTY YOUR
MIKE ABOUT THE- RICHARD MEMBERS
GREG COOK REPRESENTING THE
GOLDEN STATE POWER COOPERATIVE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. WHY IN NINETY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK WITH THE
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE I WITH NO
OFFICIAL POSITION YET THE
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE
REGARDING WORK PROTECTION.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT YOUR MIND
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARED
MEMBERS CALLING HOLLY ON THE
HELP THE CITY THE WEST
SACRAMENTO AND LONG BEACH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
LINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR MICROSCOPE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTIES OF NEVADA AND
BUTTE IN STRONG SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU IN THE OFFICE. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. LINE THIRTY
NINE YEAR MIKE IS A. ONE THIRTY
NINE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
BLIND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
YOUR MY KIDS UP. SACRAMENTO ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT. HE THANK YOU
NEXT BECAUSE. LINE FOURTEEN
HERE MIKE AT THE- WELL THE
GALLON WHY AMERICA DOT ORG IN
SUPPORT AS AMENDED TO RECOVER
SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS OF
MONEY STOLEN BY EIGHTEEN T. THE
PROPER WAY FROM THE PUBLIC
UTILITY WOULD. ACTUALLY BE
LEARNED AT THIS WORK. ONE
THIRTY FOUR YOUR MIKE IN THE
OPEN. HELLO I'M THIS IS SEAN TO
GET SOME OF THE LAUGHLIN FOR
ACCESSIBLE TEAM EUREKA IN IN
GRATEFUL AND ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT OF THIS SB FOUR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
BLIND ONE HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
HERE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HELLO AND CALLING ON
BEHALF OF TECHNICALLY
COLLABORATIVE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. THE LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CAROLYN MCINTYRE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A
SUPPORTERS AMENDED PETITION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
WORK WITH THE SENATOR THANK YOU.
NEXT BIGGER. A LINE OF ONE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO YOUR MIKE AT
THE OPEN. WAS A PARTICIPATING
IN A WAY THAT CALIFORNIA TRUCKS
REPORT. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
FIND ONE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
YOUR MAKE IT OPEN. TWENTY THREE
WHERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CENTER FOR WORLD POLICY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME. WELL NOW
WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION ON FILE SO
WE'LL GO. TO ANY SPEAKERS ON
THE LINE- THAT ARE OPPOSED TO
AS BEFORE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO-
STRAIGHT TO THE LINES MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE. FOR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOUR WEEKS PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR I SHOW NO COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. VERY WELL AND- WILL COME
TO THE COMMITTEE NOW FOR. ANY
COMMENTS OR EMOTION. WE'RE
ASKING. THAT THERE BE A MOTION-
DO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. AND IF-
CENTER EGGMAN I'D LIKE TO- THAT
I'D LIKE TO ASK IF I COULD BE A
CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL WHEN THE
OPPORTUNITY ARISES I APPRECIATE
THE SENATORS WORK LONGTIME WORK
ON THIS. AND I'M HOPING BETWEEN
THE TWO HOUSES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD GET
SOMETHING ALL THE WAY DONE THIS
YEAR AND I WOULD ALSO MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL HAVE A MOTION. AND IF
THEY'RE US INTO RUBIO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT MEASURE NOW I
KNOW THAT- THE COVER NINETEEN
THE PANDEMIC AS YOU KNOW SURELY
HIGHLIGHTED THE DEFICIENCIES
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA.
BUT I'D LIKE TO THINK OF THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AS A PANDEMIC
WITHIN A PANDEMIC AND I KNOW
MAY SEEM INSENSITIVE TO THINK
ABOUT IT IN THOSE TERMS BUT
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT'S NOT NEARLY
ALL IT'S NOT NEW TO OUR
COMMUNITIES IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
FOR A LONG TIME. AS A TEACHER
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS I CAN SAY
WITH CERTAINTY THAT THIS IS
REALLY AN ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO
TACKLE NOW- I THINK THAT THE
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY SIX SINGLE
HANDILY CAN DECIDE THE FUTURE
OF OUR STUDENTS OF OUR KIDS
THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
COMPETE IN THE LOCAL ECONOMY
LET ALONE GLOBAL ECONOMY SO I
THINK IT'S TIME THAT WE GET
AGGRESSIVE. AND FIGURE OUT THE
SOLUTION AND AGAIN I WANNA
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD BECAUSE OUR KIDS
DESERVE BETTER YOU KNOW WE'RE
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD AND YET WE CAN
PROVIDE THE VERY BASIC IN NEED
AND THAT'S BECOME A BASIC MEAT
JUST LIKE FOOD AND WATER. AND
SO I'D REALLY LIKE TO ALSO
ENCOURAGE YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION THE ASSEMBLY
NEVER WANT TO WORK TOGETHER TO
GET THIS DONE THIS YEAR AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
BAKER DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK.
BUT NO JUST BOWED MOVED TO
BUILT THE PROPERTY I'M- OKAY
WELL WE HAVE SPEAKERS PRIOR TO
THAT AND BEFORE WE MAKE THE
MOTION I WANTED TO CLARIFY THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE SPEAK THEM.
I'M IN A I'M IN A STATEMENT TO
THE RECORD WILL GO TO SENATOR
DOLLY CENTER GROVE DID YOU WANT
TO SPEAK. YOU'LL BE NEXT AFTER
CENTER CALLED. THANK YOU
RICHARD MEMBERS I. REGRETFULLY
HAVE TO STAND UP AND THEN I'M
IN OPPOSE THE BILL AND I'M
GONNA TELL YOU WHY BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR HAS.
REACHED OUT TO ME LAST YEAR AND
SHE'S DONE HER DON'T DO IT
DON'T DO IT JUSTICE. AND
RESPECT AND- BUT I WORKED ON
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE. MANY YEARS
AGO AND WE ACTUALLY AS- AN
INCREASE THE FONT AND EXTENDED
THE- THE PROGRAM JUST AS THIS
BILL. THAT DOES FOR A LONG TIME
TEN YEARS. BUT I WILL I WILL
SHARE WITH YOU. NOT ONE OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS.
ACCESS THE FUNDS AND USE THEM.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT WILL HAPPEN
AGAIN. THEY THEY THEY SUPPORT
THE COME ALONG SIDE BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY. I'M STILL IN
THE SAME PLACE IN MY
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT SERVICE.
AND WITH THE PANDEMIC WE SOUGHT
EVEN TAKE THAT EXACERBATED WISH
WE COULD HAVE WE SPENT HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND IN
THOSE PROGRAMS AND WE HAVEN'T
CHANGED. THE OUTCOME AND SO
UNTIL I SEE SOME REAL LIKE WAYS
TO GET TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT THAT VERY SMALL POPULATION
OUT THERE THERE'S 97% OF THE-
OF THE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE ACCESS IT'S THAT LAST. TWO
AND A HALF PERCENT OR 3% THAT
DON'T GET THOSE SERVICES OVER
COMMUNITIES ACTUALLY LIVE IN
ONE. IT'S HORRIBLE IT IS NOT
RIGHT AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS GOING TO CHANGE
ANYTHING I THINK IT'S GOING TO
PUT A LOT OF MONEY IN THE
SYSTEM. BUT I'LL BE SURPRISED.
IF ONE OF THOSE. FIGHTERS ARE
ARE ARE BIG PROVIDERS THE
VERIZON'S THE- SAID COMCAST
THOSE FOLKS. ACCESS THESE FUNDS
AND ACTUALLY BRING THOSE.
SERVICES TO OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT DESPERATELY NEED IT SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY AND
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I TO HAVE TO RE GREATLY
REGRETFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
BIEBER- BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THAT I HAVE BEFORE
ME IT SAYS THAT- CALIFORNIA'S
GONNA HAVE A RECORD TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN RESERVE- FOR
THIS BRAND THIS ACTIVITY AND-
THE MONEY ISN'T BEING ACCESSED
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIANS THAT DESPERATELY
NEED IT. THE OTHER ISSUES ARE
IS IT TAKES FIFTY MILLION FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION ACCESS LINES
WHICH ARE- THE- LAND LINES PER
SE WERE NOBODY USES LAND LINES
ANYMORE EVERYBODY'S ON A CELL
PHONE- AND IT ESTABLISHES IT- A
TWENTY THREE PER. CENT CHARGE.
BUT THAT'S A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS ADDITIONALLY
EVERY YEAR SO I GUESS MY ISSUE
IS THAT- DO YOU HAVE A PLANNERS
OR ANYTHING WITH THIS TWENTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS A RESERVE
WERE YOU AWARE OF THAT TWENTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS IN
RESERVE. AND THAT THE HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS. YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT EVERY YEAR THAT IT
THIS MEANT THIS BILL WILL
GENERATE WHAT WILL WHICH IS- A
RATE. INCREASE WHAT WILL THAT
MONEY BE USED FOR. IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR. YES CENTER
CONSOLES WELL THANK YOU FOR
THAT THE QUESTION SENATOR GROVE
AND- YOU KNOW I'D LOOK THAT AT
THIS VERY DIFFERENTLY I MEAN
AFTER WE'VE SEEN THROUGH
SIXTIES SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE THAT
IT WAS ON A PERCENTAGE SYSTEM
DIDN'T REALLY GET US TO THE
SIXTY SIX MILLION PER YEAR THAT
WE NEEDED IT WE ONLY WERE
GETTING ABOUT FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IF THAT.
WITH THIS BILL AND WITH THE-
THE AMENDMENTS THAT I TOOK A
THROUGH ENERGY COMMITTEE AND
WAS GRATEFUL TO DO SO- WE'RE
NOW ALLOWING THE P. YOU SEE THE
FLEXIBILITY BUT AT A AT A FLAT
FEE RATE BUT CAPPED AT A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN GET THERE-
EXPANDING THE LINES NOT JUST ON
LAND LINES BUT ON CELL PHONES
AS WELL VOICE OVER- SO THERE'S
MORE ACCESS LINES THAT WERE
TOUCHING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SO IT'S NOT JUST AFFECTING THE
RURAL COMMUNITIES THAT ARE.
PROVIDING THE REVENUE FOR THIS
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
SON BUT THEY'RE ALSO RECEIVING
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT
HOPEFULLY WITH THIS NEW MODEL-
SO THAT YOU KNOW THAT IS WHAT I
THINK- WILL BE DIFFERENT IN
ADDITION TO THE FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE
TWO TO THREE BILLION DOLLARS
POTENTIALLY COULD COME TO
CALIFORNIA BUT WE HAVE TO TAKE
A STAND NOW AND REFORM OUR OUR
FEES IN HOUSE. I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION IT DOES
AND I REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND I APPRECIATE LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER SAID
YOUR DUE DILIGENCE ON THIS
BILL- AND EVERYTHING WE'VE DONE
TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S-
IT ADDRESSES THE INTENT OF WHAT
YOU WANTED TO DO I GUESS WE
JUST HAVE A DIFFERENCE IN
AGREEMENT THAT. YOU KNOW I
STILL SEE THAT THERE'S TWENTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN RESERVE-
AND THAT'S FROM THE GOVERNOR IN
THE ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
HAVE STATED THAT THE ADDITIONAL
TAXES WERE NECESSARY IN THE
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT- SO IT'S A
TAX INCREASE VOTE FOR ANY OF US
TO TAKE THIS VOTE IN THE TWENTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS THERE IT I
JUST DON'T SEE HOW IF THEY'RE
NOT SPENDING THAT MANY AT WHY
WE SHOULD INCREASE COST HONOR.
ALL YOU KNOW CALIFORNIANS
CELLPHONES AND YOU KNOW
SERVICES IN ORDER TO PAY FOR
ADDITIONAL MONEY TO GO INTO
RESERVE ACCOUNT AND. ONCE YOU
SEEN CENTER GROVE I'M NOT I'M
NOT I UNDERSTAND YOU ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT THE- RESERVE THE-
THE GENERAL FUND RESERVE THE
TWENTY TWO BUILDINGS THAT WHEN
YOU'RE MAKING REFERENCE TO
ISSUE ANOTHER TWENTY TWO
MILLION YOU'RE MAKING REFERENCE
TO. AND IN ITS THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THE FUNDING BEING
PROVIDED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STAYS PROJECTED TO
HAVE A TO RECORD TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR RESERVE. WHAT
YOU MEAN THE GENERAL FUND
RESERVES THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT. BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
RESERVE IN THIS SPECIFIC NO NOT
IN THIS PARTICULAR ACCOUNT OKAY
THERE'S A TWENTY TWO BILLION
DOLLAR RESERVE. AND IF YOU HAVE
THOSE RESOURCES AVAILABLE IN
ALL OF US AGREE THAT WE NEED
TO. YOU KNOW COVERT TAUGHT US
THAT WE DO NEED TO. ADDRESS THE
BROADBAND SITUATION AND ALL OF
THAT THE PITFALLS THAT WE HAVE.
WITH ANY TYPE OF AND
COMMUNICATION ESPECIALLY IN OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES. BUT I JUST
DON'T SEE INCREASING TAXES ON
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING ESPECIALLY THROUGH
COVERT OVER THE LAST TWENTY YOU
KNOW. AT TWENTY FOUR TWELVE.
YEAR AND THEN INCREASING TAXES.
OKAY VERY WELL- WE SEE HERE DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE THAT WISHES
TO SPEAK. SIR BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I'M
GONNA AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE
BECOME THE MIKE SO WE CAN HEAR
YOU. I'M SPEAKING TONIGHT. ALL
RIGHT JUST THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- I. TWO ONE TO VOICE.
SOME CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO
THIS. MEASURE I COMMAND THE
AUTHOR IS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BEAVER STATED ON THE EFFORT TO.
REALLY ADDRESS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM- AS AN AUTHOR OF A
SIMILAR BILL. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND THIRTEEN. TRYING TO
ADDRESS. THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
THAT EXISTED AND ALL OF OUR
PUBLIC HOUSING HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I SECURED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THESE PUBLIC
HOUSING FACILITIES ALL IN URBAN
AREAS. WOULD BE WIRED FOR THE
INTERNET OR CABLE UNFORTUNATELY
THAT HASN'T COME. TO FRUITION
IN MANY OF THESE AREAS SO I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR EXPANDING
UPON THAT MAKING SURE THAT'S
ACROSS. OUR PRIORITY- NOT%
JUSTIN REUTERS BUT IN URBAN AS
WELL BUT I DO UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN- VOICE
BY MY COLLEAGUES AND RURAL
AREAS BECAUSE- VERY RARELY. DO
THEY GET TO SEE THE SERVICES
THAT THEY GREATLY AND THEN
BADLY NEED. AND WE'VE SEEN IT
ONLY EXACERBATING SHOW ITSELF-
THIS PANDEMIC- IN AREAS OF.
DISSING LEARNING ONLINE
LEARNING. THE NUMBER OF YOUNG
KIDSWHO CANNOT ACCESS. THE
INTERNET BECAUSE ONE- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT THERE AND
TO THE DEVICES DON'T EXIST BUT
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS MET
THE MEASURE BECAUSE AGAIN IT
DOES- TARGET THOSE UNDERSERVED
AREAS- MAKING SURE THAT- WE DO
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
I'M GONNA- DIFFER WITH MY
FRIEND FROM BAKERSFIELD.
LANDLINES ARE STILL BEING USED
I STILL HAVE A LAND LINE AND IN
MY HOME AND IT IS THE BACKBONE
TO MUCH OF WHAT WE DO BUT THE
COPPER IS NOT BEING MAINTAINED
AND I THINK WE DO HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE AND MAKE SURE. THAT
WE MAINTAIN THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WELL SO ON THAT NOTE I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE
TODAY. I'M GONNA READ THE
AMENDMENTS INTO THE RECORD JUST
SO PEOPLE ARE ARE FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT THEY ARE- A BECAUSE THERE
ARE SIX AMENDMENTS AND THEIR
SIGNIFICANCE OF FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE PUBLIC. AND TO INFORM- I
I'M- I KNOW THE MEMBERS- YES AT
CENTER GROVE JUST ON A BRIEF
RESPONSE MISTER CHAIR TO MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM GUARDINO
WHO I JUST LOVE SERVING WITH HE
ALSO CARRIES A BLACKBERRY.
THANK YOU. OKAY SO- THE
AMENDMENTS ARE OF THE FIRST. A
AMENDMENT WOULD REMOVE THE
REFERENCE 290% OF HOUSEHOLDS IN
THE DIVISION IN IN THE
DEFINITION OF A NOT UNDER
UNSERVED AREA- THE SECOND
AMENDMENT WOULD RAISE THE SPEED.
OF THE C. A. S. F. FUNDED
INFRASTRUCTURE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MEGABITS OR THE FEDERAL
FEET SPEED THRESHOLD WHICHEVER
IS GREATER. THE THIRD AMENDMENT
WOULD DELETE PROVISIONS
SPECIFYING A CAP ACCESS LINE
SURCHARGE AND INSTEAD ESTABLISH
A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
CAP ON THE TOTAL ANNUAL
SURCHARGE REVENUES FOR THE CASF
AND REMOVE PERMIT PROVISIONS OF
EXISTING LAW THAT LIMIT THE CP
IS HIS ABILITY TO CHANGE THE
UNIVERSAL SERVICE FUND
SURCHARGE PROCESS. THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT WOULD REMOVE THE BILL
SECURITATE'S SECURITISATION
PROVISIONS. THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
WOULD ESTABLISH A SUNSET DATE
OF DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
THIRTY TWO FOR THE CASF. AND
THE LAST AMENDMENT WILL ALLOW
THE CPUC TO USE A CASF TO FUND
PROJECTS TO DEPLOY BROWN BUT
TO. CERTAIN SPONSORED
FACILITIES USE FOR LOCAL AND
STATE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
INCLUDING FAIRGROUND SILVA FROM
NOT MISTAKEN- CENTER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AMENDMENTS- SO COULD
WE NOW ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
INCLUDE THOSE AMENDMENTS-
CENTER DOT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF. THE SERVER GONZALEZ THE
YOUR MAKE YOUR CLOSING
STATEMENTS YEAH THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR I THINK BOTH YOU
AND THE ENERGY COMMITTEE OF
DEFINITELY MADE THIS BILL
STRONGER SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR DILIGENCE WITH US TO OUR
SPONSORS AND COLLEAGUES AS WELL
AGAIN I'LL JUST SAY THIS IS OUR
TIME AS CALIFORNIANS TO BE ABLE
TO PUT OUR MARK AS IT PERTAINS
TO THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
FINALLY CLOSE THAT AND IT IN
THIS ONE SPACE. IT WILL PROMOTE
COMPETITION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SMALLER ISPS
ENSURE THAT UNSERVED
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY IN OUR
RURAL CALIFORNIA AREAS GET-
PRIORITY UPGRADES TO STANDARDS
AT LEAST MEET THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IF NOT MORE WHICH WE'VE DONE A
THROUGH AMENDMENTS- AND EXTENDS
THE CURRENT SPEED IT'S IN MY
OPINION NOT A TAX BUT EXTENDING
THE CURRENT SURCHARGE JUST
MAKING SURE THAT WORKS FOR
EVERY CALIFORNIANS SO WITH THAT
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB FOUR
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. WESSEL HI WESEL EINE
DOLLY. NO DOLLY GNOME BAKER HI
BAKER I GORGEOUS. BRADFORD HI
BRADFORD FINE DOT NINE DOT HI.
EGGMAN HI EGGMAN I GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ HI. GROW HERTZBERG.
MCGUIRE. MAN HI MAN I RUBIO HI
RUBIO I STERN. SURE THAT'S AS
AND ONE NOW. VERY WELL WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OF INFRACTION
MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PRESENTER CENTER DOT IF
YOU CAN FOR PRESENT FROM YOUR
DESK. ONE S. B. TWO TWO TWO
FOLLOWED BY S. B. TWO TO THREE.
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'D LIKE
TO- SB TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
TWO- THIS WOULD ESTABLISH THE
WATER RATE ASSISTANCE FUND AND
THE WATER READ ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. TO HELP PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE FOR BOTH DRINKING
WATER EXCUSE ME DRINKING AND
WASTEWATER SERVICES TO LOW
INCOME RATEPAYERS EXPERIENCING
ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS. I'LL BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE
ANALYSIS OF THE AUTHOR SUBMITS
AS AUTHORS AMEND SKEWS ME-
THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE CONSOLE
FOR WORKING WITH MY TEAM- THOSE
CHANGES. AS SOME OF YOU RECALL
I AUTHORED LEGISLATION AB FOUR
ONE ASKING THE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TO STUDY THE
ISSUE OF LOW INCOME WATER RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THE SHORT
VERSION OF THAT IS A LIRA- IN
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
THE BOARD HAS DONE JUST THAT SB
TWENTY TWO TAKES THE NEXT STEP
OF MOVING FORWARD TO IT ACT IT
ACT OUR WATER LIRA LOW INCOME
WATER RESISTANCE IS THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF S. B. TWO TWENTY
TWO. IN ADDITION TO COMPLETING
THE WATER LITERATE STUDY THE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
RECENTLY SURVEYED HUNDREDS OF
COMMUNITY WATER SYTEMS AROUND
THE STATE TO DETERMINE HOW MUCH
WATER DEBT WATER SYSTEMS
CUSTOMERS WORKS WERE ACCRUING.
THE SURVEY RESULTS ARE SOBERING
HERE'S SOME OF THE EXAMPLES OF
HOW SERIOUS THE PROBLEM OF
WATER UNAFFORDABILITY HAS
BECOME IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OVER ONE AND A HALF
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS ARE BEHIND
ON THEIR WATER BILLS THAT'S
OVER THREE MILLION PEOPLE
STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR CLEAN.
SAFE DRINKING AND WASTEWATER.
TWELVERS OF CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE DEAD OF AT
LEAST FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IT
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND THESE HOUSEHOLDS HAVE
DEBT GREATER THAN ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. COOLEY CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCRUED ABOUT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN WATER DEBT THAT
NUMBER IS INCREASING AT AROUND
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
MONTH. IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
PRE PANDEMIC OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ALREADY LOST WATER SERVICES-
DUE TO INABILITY TO PAY WATER
BILLS. THE NUMBERS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED DURING
THE PANDEMIC. GROWING WATER
DEBT IS ALSO A PROBLEM FOR
WATER SYSTEMS. FOR WATER
SYSTEMS SOME WATER SYSTEMS HAVE
LOST AS MUCH AS 30% OF THE
REVENUE IN MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THIRTY COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS
ARE FACING FINANCIAL COLLAPSE
DUE TO THE INABILITY OF THEIR
CUSTOMERS TO PAY THEIR WATER
BILLS. CALIFORNIA'S LOW INCOME
RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FOR
ELECTRICITY AND NATURAL GAS.
NOT WITHSTANDING STATE POLICY
THERE'S A STATE POLICY THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
CLEAN AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
THERE'S NO COMPARABLE WATER
RESISTANCE PROGRAM FOR PUBLICLY
OWNED AND WATER. PUBLICLY OWNED
A COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS IT'S
ABOUT TIME THAT WE HAVE A STATE
WIDE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE TO PAY FOR
DRINKING AND WASTEWATER. THAT'S
TO BE AMENDED SB TWO TWO TWO
LAYS OUT THREE CATEGORIES OF
ASSISTANCE INCLUDING DIRECT
WATER BILL ASSISTANCE AND WATER
CRISIS ASSISTANCE. THE BILL
REQUIRES THE BOARD TO DEVELOP
GUIDELINES FOR PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION IN EXPENDITURE
PLAN THAT WOULD IDENTIFY THE
FUNDING NEEDS FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
ADDRESS IDENTIFIED ANY FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THE RATES AS PROGRAM
THAT IS A PARALLEL
CONVERSATION- THAT IS OCCURRING
BUT IT NEEDS TO OCCUR. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS PROVIDED
SOME ONE TIME FUNDING AND MEGAN
SOON BUT WE NEED A CONTINUING
SOURCE OF STATE AND PRIVATE
FUNDING AS WELL. GOODFAITH
NEGOTIATIONS BEEN TAKING PLACE
BETWEEN THE STAKEHOLDERS OF MY
TEAM. WHILE THE AMENDMENTS HAVE
ADDRESS SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS RAISED BY STAKEHOLDERS
I KNOW THAT THERE'S MORE TO
WORK ON IT I'M ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT. WHAT
I'M ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE TO
ALLOW ME TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSIONS AND GET HIS LONG
OVERDUE PROGRAM ESTABLISH ONE
FINAL NOTE. I WANT TO THANK ACW
EIGHT C. MUA AT CW A FOR THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE ON THIS
BILL AS WELL AS MY NEXT BILL SB
TWO TO THREE. ALL THE PHONE IS
JONATHAN NELSON FROM THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER IT LUCY
HERNANDEZ FROM A SAFER ADVISORY
GROUP MEMBER- IN WEST OCEAN-
AND WEST COAST RESIDENT
RESIDENTS USE MAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ON THIS
CRITICALLY NEEDED PROGRAM.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO THE
SPEAKERS IN A MOMENT BUT I JUST
WANT TO APPLY THE SAME RULES AS
FILLED OUT ALL THE OTHER BILLS
ARE ON. A FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. FIFTEEN FOR SUPPORT
FIFTEEN FOR OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TO LEAD SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL JONATHAN NELSON AND
LUCY HERNANDEZ WE HAVE ONE LEAD
SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION CINDY
TALK WE WILL BEGIN WITH THE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. BEGINNING
WITH JONATHAN NELSON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JONATHAN NELSON AND I'M
THE POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION FIGHTING FOR STATE
AND AFFORDABLE WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE COSPONSORED CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL PROJECTED THAT THE
COUNT ABILITY. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AS WELL AS THE
WATER FOUNDATION. WE ARE HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF XP TWO TWO
TWO WHICH WHICH FINALLY PUT
INTO PLACE A FRAMEWORK FOR A
STATEWIDE LOW INCOME WATER RATE
THAT THE TENT AROUND. EACH TIME
I HAVE I JUST WANT TO STRESS
THAT IN ADDITION TO THE ONE
BILLION AND CAN DEMOCRATIC
WATER DATA CENTER DODD
MENTIONED. WATER
UNAFFORDABILITY HAS BEEN A LONG
STANDING ISSUE AND WELL PRETTY
THAT PANDEMIC. APPLE JEFF. IN
NINETEEN A LOAN THAT WE KNOW
THAT THE STATE WATER BOARD
FOUND ROUGHLY HALF A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WERE IMPACTED BY
WATER SHUT OFF AND OF COURSE
THE WHOLE POINT OF THE EIGHTY
FOUR ONE REPORT WHICH CAME OUT
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC BEGAN WHAT
TO RESPOND TO THAT LONG
RECOGNIZED GAP AROUND WATER
AFFORDABILITY YEAH. THIRTY
MENTIONED WE HAVE AFFORDABILITY
PROGRAMS FOR NEARLY ALL OTHER
BASIC UTILITIES EVEN HELP ON
BUT NOT FOR WATER AND THAT IT'S
BEEN HURTING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES FOR DECADES
SB TWO TO TAKE THE FIRST STEP
TO ADDRESS THIS GAP BY PUTTING
INTO PLACE A THOUGHTFUL
FRAMEWORK FOR A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM ALONG WITH REQUIREMENTS
FOR A TRANSPARENT PUBLIC
PROSTATE. FOR US WHICH IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE AND IT'S
ALSO A MATTER OF RACIAL
INEQUITY. WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE NOW
LOSING HER. I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS LISTED HERNANDEZ I
AM A RESIDENT OF A SMALL LITTLE
COMMUNITY AND TULARE COUNTY THE
REASON OF MY CALL TODAY IS TO
URGE THE SENATE TO TAKE ACTION
AND BOARDING PAPER TO SB TWO
TWENTY TWO. I CAN HEAR IT
BECAME APPARENT THAT OLDER. AND
FOR SO MANY IN TOWN WHO
STRUGGLE EACH MONTH. BOB FOR
THEIR WATER BILLS. OUR FAMILIES
WERE STRUGGLING TO PAY OUR
WATER BILLS EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. AND DEMOCRATS MADE IT
WORSE. EDUARDO AFFORDABILITY
AT. A FITNESS PROGRAM WILL BE
HELPFUL TO OUR CULTURE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. OUR FAMILY TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN WATER AND OTHER
NECESSITIES THIS IS URGENT
PLEASE VOTE IN FAVOR TO ASK ME
TO TWENTY TWO TO SUPPORT OUR
FAMILIES I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS. BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THERE ARE
NO SPEAKERS IN THE GALLERY
THEIR NOSE BECAUSE REMOTE ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WE'LL GO NOW TO THE-
PHONE LINES. TO HEAR SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TWO TWO
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. THE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT WE ARE SO
SPEAKERS- OF. WISHING TO
TESTIFY TO LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS
TO THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON SB TWO TWO
TWO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
RECOMMEND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. IN
LINE AT ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP. ONE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. SH AFTERNOON HEARING
MEMBERS CAN GO ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
THE COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN YOUR MY KIDS OPEN. WHAT
THE ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN COURT. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS THIS IS
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORTER
THAT SPEAK TO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. BLIND OF ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE YOU'RE MY
COULD HELP WITH. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS VETERAN
TRANSMITTED ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE YOUR MIKE
AT THE- HI NATALIE VERGARA ON
BEHALF OF. REPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE
FORTY THREE YOUR MIKE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIRED HUESO AN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
CENTRAL COAST ENERGY SERVICES-
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. LINE
THIRTY SIX YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS NOT A QUICKLY- WIND
HERE TO DANCE A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER AND PART OF THAT THE
MOTOR THIS OTHER THAN THE
ENTITLEMENT FROM A DOUBLE
HEIGHT. BUT NOT COMMITTEE
MEMBER FROM EAST LA I AM HERE
TO SUPPORT BILL I NEED TO TREAT
YOU AND I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
BE HERE FOR. THE TWO TO THREE
WHICH I HIGHLY- THE PRODUCT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EXPECT HER. LINE ONE HI FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR MARKET UP. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS BECAUSE
DOLLARS COULD NOT ACTION. GOING
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO TWO TWO
AND ON BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION BY THE
PRINCETON'S AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. BLIND
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE YOUR
MIKE AT THE- CAITLYN CLEARWATER
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA COULD
KEEP RELIANCE COACHELLA VALLEY
WATERKEEPER INLAND EMPIRE
WATERKEEPER ORANGE COUNTY COAST
KEEPER HUMBOLDT BEEKEEPERS LOS
ANGELES WATERKEEPER MODERATOR
KEEPER RUSSIAN RIVERKEEPER SAN
DIEGO KERR KEEPER. SANTA
BARBARA CHANNEL KEEPER. AND
YUBA RIVER WATERKEEPER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT BIGGER.
THE LINEONE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
YOU'RE MY COULD UP. GOOD NEWS.
YOU CAN'T BE ON BEHALF OF LIFE
AND OUR ONLINE POVERTY IN
STRONG SUPPORTER AT THE TWO TWO
TWO. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. A
LINE OF ONE HUNDRED TEN YOU'RE
MY COULD HELP. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN- WESTERN CANADIAN
MEMBERS THE PEOPLE AND THAT
ALONG WITH ENERGY SETON'S FROM
COURT. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX YOUR
MY KIDS UP. I'M NOT. I REALLY
THOUGHT OF IT AND ON MONDAY I
WANTED TO MANDATE YEAH I MEAN
I'M- GLAD IT WON'T THE FIFTY
SEVENTH IN EXACTLY YOU'D BE
LOOKING AT GAINS. IT MAY BE
THERE ARE. OKAY NOW WHAT HOW
MANY CALLS. HI MY NAME IS MARK
AND I PART OF COLD OF A AYE
AYES THAT YOU CAN SUPPORT AND.
TWO TWO TWO TO TWO TO THREE.
MORE COMMUNE IS POOR HAS TRIED
TO. AND THE WHAT KEEPING UP
WITH THE WATER CRISIS REALLY
HARD THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
LINE ONE HI YEAR IS A- HI MY
NAME IS BORN IN HIM BECAUSE ON
BEHALF OF THE LAST PLAN FOR
YOUR COUNTRY AND OF FUTURE WELL
DO THREE UNFORTUNATE CAN'T
PRONOUNCE ABOUT DISCUSSIONS YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO YOUR MY KIDS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS TO DO AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE OUR
COALITION INVESTED THE
CALIFORNIA TULARE COUNTY AND
THESE BILLS S. B. TWO TWO TWO
THAT TO DO GREEN WILL HAVE TO
READ ME WATER REACHES WITH
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. THAT
ARE YOU ARMENIAN PACK AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT BEACH TO BILLS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
THE LINE SIX THREE YOUR MIKE IN
THE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON-
SENATE CHAIR AND SENATE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HASN'T BEEN
GIVING I LA SALLE COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
SPEAKER. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE YOUR MY KIDS UP. OUR
TEAM AS WE- NEED WHEN I SEVEN
NUMBER THAT ONLY GOT THE LEAD.
THE LITTLE MERMAID ALEXANDER-
OKAY ET NOBODY AT THE IDEA. YOU
DON'T MIDDLE EAST REPUBLICAN
IOWA YOUR LITTLE AB AVALON I
THINK LOOKING ONE APPLE YEAH
NOT A SINGLE THING PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THAT WORK IN THE
COMPLIANCE OF THE BILL YOU'RE
LOOKING AT FROM ON MONDAY
ALLOWED YOU. WHEN I WALK ON THE
THAT. I WANT TO NEXT BIG
PROJECTS. BLIND AND NINE YOUR
MY COULD OPEN. FOUR MINUTES
SUCH A BALL HIGH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND I JUST WANT TO
REMIND THE SPEAKERS TO PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE MEASURE BUT OUR LOW
GOVERNMENT BY YOUR PERFORMANCE
BY THE MOCO SOLAMENTE
INCIDENTS- KNOWN TODAY SYSTEM
AFFILIATES COULD NOT ORGANISE
SOON HE ARE SUPPOSED TO A AN
ESTIMATE EITHER. FIVE WE CAN
ASK OUR THE NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
THE LINE AT NINETY YOUR
MICROSCOPE. BLINDSIDED ME. HI
BELIEVE I WITH THE COMMITTEE
WHAT CENTER- THANK YOU CHAIR
AND COME MEMBERS- ALSO CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
POLICY LEAGUE PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
RESPONSIBILITY LA AND SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER PLEASE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. ADJOURNMENTS IF
YOU WOULD ALLOW ME- THE ABILITY
I WILL GO AHEAD AND TRY TO BEG
FOR A CONSTITUENT BERGEN AND
LET HER GIVE UP ON THE
CONFERENCE. NOT INTENSIVELY.
ORDER TO COMBAT YOU. I MEAN.
THANK YOU. WHAT. THREE BILLION
TO PROPERTY. TO THANK YOU
PUBLIC THE REST YES ARAMBULA.
THE REST EXPLICABLE. LINE ONE
HI SIXTY- MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING MA'AM AARON
RODGERS ENOUGH CAN BY INTO
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
BECAUSE- LINE ONE SIXTY ONE
YOU'RE MY COULD UP. GOOD
EVENING MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS
LATEST EMORY ON OF THE BUILDING
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ALLIANCE
WHICH COMPRISES A FIFTY FIVE
PROGRESSIVE ORGANIZATIONS IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT S. B. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. AND
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME OKAY RUN
ON TIME WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
OF AN ORGANIZED PRESENTATION BY
CINDY TOOK. A IS CINDY TOOK ON
THE LINE. YES PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU SIR HUESO AND MEMBERS
CINDY TACK WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
OUR MEMBERS ARE PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES AN AWKWARD HAS AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON SB TWO TWO TWO. WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT SAID
SENATOR DODD MADE IN THE APRIL
FIVE CHRISTIAN BUT WE STILL
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL AS
YOU KNOW. THIS EVENING I WILL
NOTE THREE ISSUES- FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION. THE
FIRST HAS TO DO WITH PRIORITY
BECAUSE THE ANALYSIS ASKS THE
QUESTION WHAT IS THE PRIORITY
AND WE SUGGEST THAT THE
PRIORITY ON WATER AFFORDABILITY
SHOULD BE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR TO PROVIDE ONE
TIME STATE FUNDING FROM THE
BUDGET SURPLUS AND SEPARATE
FROM THIS BILL. TO HELP PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES ADDRESS THE
CUSTOMER WATER DEBT THAT HAS
ACCRUED DURING THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC EMERGENCY.
THAT'S THE FIRST POINT SECOND
ISSUE- NOW FOCUSED ON THE BILL
ITSELF HAS TO DO WITH THE SCOPE
OF SB TWO TO TWO AND WE AGREE
WITH SENATOR DODD THAT THERE
COULD BE AN ATTRACTIVE AND
EFFICIENT WATER LOW INCOME RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR LIRE FOR
SHORT. IT IS DRAFTED SB TWO TWO
TWO GOES BEYOND A LEE OR
PROGRAMS WITH THE INCLUSION OF
OTHER PROPOSALS AND A SHORT
SOMETIMES IS- VERY HORT
PREFERENCES BUT IN ON PAGE
THREE PAGE FIVE PAGE PAGE SIX
THERE'S DIFFERENT. REFERENCES
TO OTHER PROPOSALS. AND WE SEE
THAT CREATING A LEANER PROGRAM
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
A LOW INCOME RATE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR WATER AND
WASTEWATER. THAT ALONE IS A BIG
LIST AND THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
SHOULD BE NARROWED TO THAT.
THAT'S OUR OUR SECOND COMMENT
TODAY AND THEN THE THIRD ISSUE
HAS TO DO WITH A GREAT DATA AND
THE WAY THE BILL IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN IT PROPOSES TO HAVE THE
STATE COLLECT TO RATE AND
BOUNDARY DATA FROM EACH OF THE
THOUSANDS OF PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS. WE ASK YOU WHY IS IT
PROPOSING TO DO THAT AND THE
SPONSORS TOLD US THAT THE
PROPOSAL IS FAIR FOR
DETERMINING HOW MUCH OF THE
BENEFIT HOUSEHOLD WOULD RECEIVE
FROM THE PROGRAM. AND WE THINK
THAT SORTING RATE DATA FROM
EACH OF THOUSANDS OF SYSTEMS IS
UNNECESSARILY COMPLICATED WAY
TO DEVELOP WHAT THE BENEFIT IS
FOR HOUSEHOLDS IN THE PROGRAM.
SO WE SUGGEST DELETING THAT
PART OF THE BILL IT'S AT PAGE.
EIGHT NINE NINE TO ELEVEN AND
TAKING A SIMPLE APPROACH AND
SETTING THE BENEFIT AND THAT
WOULD AVOID UNNECESSARY FUND
ADMINISTRATION COSTS SO THAT
MORE OF THE FUNDING. CAN GO TO
HELP LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THAT CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY AND
ARE QUICKLY SHIFTS THE TIME
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE- THIS
EVENING THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
COMMENTS AND FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THERE ARE NO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY OR IN ROOM ONE. TWELVE
SO WE WILL MOVE TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF TWO TWO TWO ONE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO TO TWO. AND WE ASK THE
SPEAKERS TO LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS OF THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE. ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AN ONLINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN YOUR MIKE
IS A- I DON'T KNOW BY PROVIDING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION APPEAR
LISTED ON THE ANALYSIS OF THE
CODE MUST AMENDED. POSITION AND
WHILE WE ARE CONTINUING TO
THINK AMENDMENTS WE FEEL ENOUGH
PROGRESS IS THE NEED TO REMOVE
THAT OPPOSITION NUMBER NOW TO
WATCH. IT AND ENDED THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
BLIND ONE HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
YOUR MY KIDS UP. GOOD EVENING
CALL HER LIQUOR WITH THE SAN
JUAN WATER DISTRICT OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. BLIND ONE HUNDRED FORTY
THREE YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS BASS OFF SO ON BEHALF
OF THE CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT REALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THE COMIC OF AQUA INTERPOSING
LAST MINUTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE YOUR MIKE IS
A. GOOD EVENING REALLY LOCUSTS
ON BEHALF OF ONE OF OUR WATER
DISTRICT ARE COMMENTS ARE IN
LINE WITH AUCKLAND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO MY CEMENTED THANK
YOU. NEXT BIG. THE LINE SIXTY
ONE YOUR MIKE IS UP. THANK YOU
TERM MEMBERS THIS IS ANTHONY
TAMA NOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
ALIGNING OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE
EIGHTY FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD UP.
THANK YOU HANNAH DAVIDSON FROM
THE HIDDEN VALLEY LAKE
COMMUNITY SERVICES DISTRICT WE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH AQUA
AND WE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. LINE
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YOUR
MIKE AT THE. RYANAIR JACKING
WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY AND WE ARE NOT. THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY YOUR MY KIDS UP.
KAREN SENATORS INCLUDING LEAN
ON BEHALF OF MESA WATER
DISTRICT IN THE TWELVE
UTILITIES DISTRICT A PROPOSAL
SUBMITTED POSITION ON THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. LINE SIXTY SIX- MY
COULD OPEN. YOU ARE NOT
THINKING KANA AND ON BEHALF OF
THE IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT
AND EAT THE VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
IN LINE WITH AWKWARD COMMON.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. ONE ONE
HUNDRED I APOLOGIZE THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
OKAY VERY WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW WILL COME TO- THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS AND
CENTER DOT LOOKS LIKE YOUR FEAR
MEMONS AWAY FROM UNIVERSAL
SUPPORT FOR YOUR BILL SO. HELLO
MORE WORK TO DO BUT GLAD WE'RE
GETTING YOU. CLOSER TO YOUR
GOAL SARGANT GONZALEZ. JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
SENATOR DODD FOR BRINGING- BOTH
THIS BILL AS WELL AS AS B. TWO
TWO THREE EIGHT HAPPY COLE
AUTHOR AND- LOOK FOR TO PUSHING
THIS THROUGH OUR LEGISLATURE
THIS IS MUCH NEEDED THANK YOU.
GRAYSON- EGGMAN. THANK YOU AB.
AND I APPECIATE YOUR TENACITY
WITH THIS CENTER DIED AND I
CAN'T BELIEVE THE STATE
CALIFORNIA HASN'T FIGURED THIS
OUT YET BUT WE ARE SO LONG
PASSAGE EMBARRASSING WE HAVEN'T
FIGURED THIS OUT. THAT SAID I
DON'T THERE'S STILL NO WAY TO
PAY FOR THIS IN HERE AND SO I
STILL HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
FUNDING SOURCE- THREE STILL
HAVE CONCERNED AT SOME OF THESE
DISTRICTS ARE SMALL AND AT RISK
OF SOME OF THE PEOPLE THAT THEY
SERVE SO I THINK WE STILL HAVE
WORK TO DO ON ON THAT- BUT I
CERTAIN THE FORTY SUPPORTING IT
TODAY AND MOVING MOVING THIS
ALONG AND WITH YOU REMAIN-
DETERMINED TO GET THIS ISSUE
SOLVED. SENATE DALY IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU MISTER I
GOT A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
FOR ME. SO I REPRESENT.
HUNDREDS OF VERY SMALL- TWENTY
SERVICE DISTRICTS THAT SUPPLY
WATER IN WATER AND I GET CALLS
IN A LOT DURING CODE WE GOT A
LOT OF CALLS ABOUT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS PAYMENTS
THE LIKES. AND KNOWING THAT
WE'RE UP AGAINST PROP TO
EIGHTEEN SO MANY TIMES THEY PUT
UP OF A BALL- THE VOTE TO RAISE
THEIR RATES NOT ONLY JUST
BECAUSE- THEY HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE NON PAYING BUT THEY ALSO
HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT
HAVE BEEN REGULATED ON TOP OF
THEM. SO I'M TRYING TO GRASP
WHAT THE HOW THIS WOULD WORK I
MEAN IT AT THE END OF THE DAY.
LOOK WE ALL WANT TO HELP PEOPLE
WHO ARE DOWN AND OUT AND HAVE
HAVE. DUE TO COVERT OR WHAT ARE
THE EVER THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE.
BUT I REPRESENT I'M JUST GONNA
TALK ABOUT BIEBER WERE
ACTUALLY. IS A COMMUNITY
SERVICE DISTRICT. THAT HAS BEEN
REGULATED BY THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS SIGMA NOW AS
WELL. AND I HAVE OF A COMMUNITY
OF VERY POOR PEOPLE. THAT
LITERALLY CAN'T AFFORD TO RAISE
THE RATES SO THAT WHEN THEY TRY
TO. PASS THE RATE UP TO
ACTUALLY TAKE CARE OF THE- THE
THINGS THEY NEED TO MAKE THE
WATER SAFE AND TO FIX THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S AGING AND
ME MY COMMUNITIES I MEAN. SOME
OF THE SYSTEMS ARE. FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD THEIR STEEL
PIPES THERE'S ROSTERS LEAKAGE.
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE TO FIX THAT AND THAT
BUT THE CUSTOMERS NEVER RAISE
THE RATE. AND SO. CAN YOU GIVE
ME SOMEIT FOR INFORMATION ON
HOW THIS. WOULD ACTUALLY
BENEFIT. THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
TRYING TO OPERATE THE SYSTEMS-
AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
BECAUSE I'M I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
GET THERE. ASSEMBLY WHO'S VERY
FRUSTRATED. WITH TE PROCESS OF
TWO EIGHTEEN AND NOT ALLOWING.
THEM TO BE ABLE TO FIX THEIR
OWN SERVICES. PER SHARE THE-
CENTER FROM BIEBER'S COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS. THIS BILL SIMPLY
PUT ONLY SET UP AN ACCOUNT IN
THE STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE TO
BE ABLE TO DEPOSIT MONEY AND
FOR YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL MONEY
THIS COMING A- AND- ALSO-
NONPROFIT MONEY THERE'S A LOT
OF NON PROFITS THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES ARE VERY.
INTERESTED IN THESE TYPE OF
PROGRAMS AND THEN ALSO WITH THE
MONIES ARE COMING INTO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I AM
WORKING. OVERTIME WILL CONTINUE
WORKING OVERTIME FRIDAY TO GET
MONEY INTO THE L. IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM- IS FAR IT
AND THEN IT ALSO SEND SET
STANDARDS OF HOW. HE HOW THAT'S
YOU KNOW WORKS YOU HEARD SOME
CRITICISMS OF THIS BILL BY THE
HOUSE SOME OF THOSE AGENCIES.
HI YELLOW COMMITTEE WHEN YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THEM LIKE I DID IN
THE LAST BILL DID IT IN MAYBE
YOU MIGHT EVEN BE TALKING. MORE
ABOUT SB TWO TO THREE THAN TWO
TWO TWO BUT. HE TO TWO DOZEN.
TWO EIGHTY IS LAW IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THIS BILL NOR TWO
TO THREE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT LATER DOES ANYTHING TO
CHANGE THAT WHATSOEVER.
EFFECTED TOTALLY RECOGNIZES
THAT THAT IS VERBOTEN TO USE
RATEPAYERS MONEY- OTHER
PEOPLE'S RATEPAYERS MONEY TO
HELP OTHER PEOPLE- YELLED WITH
WITH WITH THE RATE. BUT WITH
THE RATE LOW INCOME RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. DID I
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION WELL I
THINK IT'S A SORT OF YES IT I
MEAN I KNOW. THE PROBLEM THAT I
THINK THERE'S NOBODY THROUGH
THE DESERT IN THE PROBLEM. IT'S
ON HOW YOU FIX THE PROBLEM IS I
THINK THAT WE'RE ALL KIND OF
SCRATCH YOUR HEADS WITH. AND SO
I MEAN WE WE'VE USED GRANTS
THROUGH WATER BONDS AND WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE EXHAUSTED THOSE FOR
MOST AS COMMITTEES IF THEY
HAVE. THE STAFF TO EVEN BE ABLE
TO WRITE THE GREAT. I MEAN IT'S
SO MANY. THE AND I'M ASSUMING
THIS IS IN YOUR DISTRICT AS
WELL AS IT IS MINE IF YOU HAVE
A- YOU KNOW A TREE SITTERS
DISTRICT DIRECTOR WHO'S THE GUY
THAT FIXES THE LEAKS AS WELL
SINCE THE BILL'S OUT. WHOSE
WILLIS EXPECTED RIGHT TO GRANT
TO TRY TO GET SOME MONEY FROM
THE- PROP SIXTY FOUR WHATEVER.
THERE WAS. A LITTLE POTS OF
MONEY SO I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO BUT I'M-
NOT SURE HOW. THIS ACTUALLY.
ACHIEVE THAT FOR ALL THOSE. TO
ME SERVICE DISTRICTS OUT THERE
OR WATER SUPPLIERS. WHAT FIGURE
THE CENTER FROM STOCKTON SAID
AT ALL THIS IS BEEN A PROBLEM.
FOR A LONG TIME IN THIS YEAR
NOW. WITH OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH THE WATER DEBT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT
CONTINUES TO BE A PROBLEM. THE
WORST LOOK AT I'M NOT LOOKING
TOWARDS THE WORST THING THAT
EVER HAPPENS. BUT IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
OPPOSITION THIS BILL. THE WORST
THING THAT HAPPENS WE DON'T GET
THE MONEY. WE SET AN ACCOUNT UP
TO THE STATE. TREASURY
DEPARTMENT- WITH SOME STANDARDS
AND THAT WOULD REALLY BE A
SHAME. IF NOTHING HAPPENED
THERE BUT THAT'S- THE WORST
THAT CAN HAPPEN WITH THIS BILL.
THE POSITIVE THINGS THAT CAN
HAPPEN WITH THIS BILL. IS WE
GET FEDERAL MONEY THERE. WE GET
NONPROFIT MONEY. THERE WE
REALLY PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTHS ARE- IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO GET BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS. TO
MAKE IT A REAL PROGRAM. TO HELP
REAL PEOPLE. IT ALSO. REAL HARD
WORKING WATER UTILITIES. THAT
BECAUSE OF THESE PEOPLE NOT.
ABLE TO PAY THEIR BILLS. THE
WATER UTILITIES THEMSELVES ARE
IN TROUBLE. SO EVERY PERSON WHO
GETS HELPED. WILL IN THE ED.
HELPFUL. WATER UTILITY BY
PAYING THEIR BILL. THEY YOU.
OKAY WHO ELSE TO HAVE ON THE
QUEUE AND OF COURSE WERE ASKING
FOR A MOTION ON S. B. TO PASS
AS AMENDED REFERS TO MEN AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON TAT. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SIR BRADFORD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY SURCHARGE
ONE MAKE SOME CLOSING
STATEMENTS. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THAT'S PERFECT
BECAUSE- THE PREVIOUS STATEMENT
PRETTY MUCH SUMS IT UP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CLICK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB TWO TWO TWO BY
SENATOR DODD. TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY WESSEL HI
WESEL EINE DOLLY NO THE ONLY
KNOWN BAKER HI. BAKER HI FORGES.
BRADFORD HI BRADFORD AYE DODD.
HI DODD HI EGGMAN HI EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ ALL RIGHT.
GROW. HERTZBERG I. GOT ME THANK
YOU AYE HERTZBERG AYE. MCGUIRE.
MAN HI MAN I RUBIO. STERN. AS
AND WANNA. THANK YOU HOLD THE
ROLE OF PREFER ABSENT MEMBERS
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM SIX S. B.
TWO TO THREE BY SENATOR DODD
RELATED TO DISCONTINUATION OF
RESIDENTIAL WATER SERVICE
CENTER DODD WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SB TWO TO THREE STRENGTHENS AND
EXTENDS EXISTING STATUTORILY
REQUIRED PROTOCOLS AND
PROCEDURES TO PROTECT LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
FACING WATER SERVICE
DISCONNECTIONS DUE TO THE WATER
CUSTOMERS INABILITY TO PAY
THEIR BILL. ONCE AGAIN I'M
ACCEPTING ALL THE SUGGESTIONS
ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS
AS OFFERS AMENDMENTS I WON'T
REPEAT THE SOBERING FINDINGS OF
THE WATER BOARD SURVEY ON WATER
DEBT I HIGHLIGHTED FROM SB TWO
TWO TWO LET'S JUST SAY HOSE
FINDINGS ILLUMINATED A PROBLEM
WHICH HAS BEEN GETTING WAY
WORSE FOR YEARS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN I AUTHORED SB NINE
NINE EIGHT WHICH ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM OF WATER SHUT OFFS.
SOME CRITICS OF SB TWO TO THREE
ARE ASKING WHY WE NEED THIS
BILL IN LIGHT OF NINE NINE
EIGHT THE ANSWER IS TWO FOLD
FIRST IS WATER THAT HAS
DEEPENED THE PROBLEM PEOPLE
LOSING ACCESS TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER AND WASTEWATER IT'S
REACHED CRISIS PROPORTIONS.
SECOND THE FINAL VERSION OF
NINE NINE EIGHT REFLECTED MANY
COMPROMISES I MADE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED BY OPPONENTS.
SB TWO TO THREE IS INTENDED TO
FILLSOME GAPS LEFT BY THE
FINAL VERSION OF S. B. NINE
NINE EIGHT. FOR EXAMPLE.
CURRENT SHUTTLE PROJECT
PROTECTION. IS LIMITED TO WATER
SYSTEMS WITH TWO HUNDRED OR
MORE CONNECTIONS. SB TWO TO
THREE PROPOSES TO INCLUDE
SMALLER SYSTEMS IN PROTECTION
PROTOCOLS. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
FOR WATER AGENCIES TO SHUT TE
WATEROFF WHEN THE RATE PAYERS
DELINQUENT FOR SIXTY DAYS.
THAT'S A TIGHT TIMELINE FOR LOW
INCOME WATER LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLD TRYING TO FIND ONE
THOUSAND EVEN FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO CATCH UP ON THEIR
CURRENT BILL. LET ME JUST TELL
YOU AS A FORMER- ENTREPRENEUR
IN THE WATER BUSINESS I HAD
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
CUSTOMERS THE IDEA OF SHUTTING
SOMEBODY DOWN IT'S SIXTY DAYS.
FRANKLY TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN I
WAS IN BUSINESS WHAT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE SB TWO TO THREE
AS AMENDED GIVES THE RATEPAYER
NINETY DAYS OR WHEN THE REPAIRS
ACCUMULATED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS IN DEBT. BEFORE SHUT
OFFS CAN COMMENCE. SB TWO TO
THREE WAVES RECONNECTION FEES
FOR RATE PAYERS WHO CERTIFIES
LOW INCOME OR HAVE VULNERABLE
PER ADMIRABLE NORMAL PERSON IN
THE HOUSEHOLD WE'RE TRYING TO
DIG OUT FIVE HUNDRED OR A
THOUSAND DOLLARS WATER DEBT.
RECONNECTION FEES DON'T HELP
YOUR PROBLEM. THERE ARE SEVERAL
OTHER SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO
CURRENT LAW MADE BY S. B. TWO
TWO THREE BUT I WANT TO ADDRESS
WHAT I MIGHT BE. WHAT MIGHT BE
THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL
PROVISION AND THAT'S DEBT
FORGIVENESS. THE INTRODUCED
VERSION OF THE BILL REQUIRED
WATER SYSTEMS TO OFFER INDEBTED
LOW INCOME RATEPAYER IN A
RESEARCH MANAGEMENT PLAN. SB
TWO TO THREE AS AMENDED
REQUIRES A WATER SYSTEMS TO
MAKE FINDINGS ON THE RECORD
THAT THEY HAVE NO OTHER
AVAILABLE RESOURCES TO FORGIVE
DEBT. WHERE NON REPAIR FUNDS
ARE AVAILABLE IN ARREARS PLANTS
A RESEARCH PLAN WOULD BE
OFFERED. ARREARS PLANS ARE
INTENDED TO HELP THE REPAIR
CRAWL OUT OF INDEBTEDNESS AS
LONG AS THEY STAY CURRENT ON
NEW WATER BILLS LET ME REPEAT
THAT. AS LONG AS THEY STAY
CURRENT ON NEW WATER BILLS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE SHUT
OFF BUT IF THEY ARE NOT CURRENT
THEN THAT'S A DIFFERENT STORY
ONE FINAL POINT SP TWO TWO
THREE NOT ONLY PROTECTS
STRUGGLING RATEPAYERS. BUT WHEN
COMBINED WITH WATER LIRA ALSO
PROTECTS SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
THAT ARE IN A PRECARIOUS
FINANCIAL CONDITION BY
PRESERVING REVENUE FLOW. AS
WITH TO THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE
DONE ON TWO TO THREE AND I'M
COMMITTED TO DOING SO WE'RE
LISTENING TO THE STAKEHOLDERS.
IN IMPROVING THE BILL WITH
EVERY WORKING SESSION. I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BILL. ON
THE PHONE ARE MIKEY WITNESSES
MICHAEL CLAIBORNE AND MORE
FEINSTEIN. IN ADDITION THE LARA
FEINSTEIN WE HAVE- SPEAKER THE
LEAD OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
CHRIS CENTERS AND WILL GET THE
TO THAT PERSON WHEN. WE COME TO
OPPOSITION WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
FIRST WITH MICHAEL CLAIBORNE
FOLLOWED BY LARA FEINSTEIN. IF
THEY'RE ON THE LINE. GOOD
EVENING TO THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MICHAEL
CLAIBORNE A DIRECTING ATTORNEY
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHICH IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE NONPROFIT
WORKING ALONGSIDE IN
REPRESENTING LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN EIGHT TELL ABOUT IT.
I'M ALSO ADDING SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER ACTION
MANY WATER CENTER AND WATER
FOUNDATION. THE REALITY IS THAT
ACCESS TO TAP WATER IS NOT
UNIVERSAL IN THE STATE AND AT
THE EXISTING SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING FOR MANY LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE LOST
ACCESS TO WATER AND MODE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
GET SHOT. THIS IS A STATEWIDE
PROBLEM THAT'S THOUGH SOME
AREAS ARE HIT HARDER THAN
OTHERS HI GREAT THE SHOPS WERE
IN LOS ANGELES. AND SANTA MARIA
RANCHO CORDOVA HOLDEN BELL
GARDENS. NORWALK AND FACTORS-
KIDDING HIRED HI IT'S GREAT TO
WATER GET. SOME WATER SHUT UP
WHY CURRICULA AS FIFTY DOLLARS
AT THE TWO TO THREE AS WHETHER
WE MEANT WHAT WE SAID IN TWENTY
TWELVE WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED AB SIXTY TO EIGHTY FIVE.
WHICH DECLARED ACCESS TO AN
ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER HUMAN
RIGHTS AFFORDED TO EVERY HUMAN
BEING IN THE STATE. SO THE
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH IT'S BEEN ON
BOOKS FOR NAY A DAY. LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS LOSE ACCESS TO
WATER IN THEIR HOMES WHEN THEY
FALL BACK BEHIND ON THEIR WATER
BILL. AS SHUT OFF AT THE FAMILY
FALL SO FAR BEHIND THEY CANNOT
CATCH UP. IT IS AN ACT
INEQUITABLE SYSTEM PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE HIT HARDEST WITH
BLACK FAMILIES TWICE. AS LIKELY
AS WHITE TO EXPERIENCE
WATERSHED OUT. SB THREE TWO
THREE WOULD HELP BY EXTENDING
AND STRENGTHENING WATER SHUT
OFF PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE THAT
SHOPS ARE USED ONLY AS A LAST
RESORT. ESPECIALLY WHEN APPLIED
LOW INCOME AND VULNERABLE
HOUSEHOLDS. WE HAVE PUT IN
CENTRAL TIME AND EFFORT WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS AND ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THAT EFFORT. WE ASK
THE COMMITTEE ENSURE THAT STATE
IS DOING EVERYTHING IT CAN TO
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN DO NOT
GROW UP IN HOMES. I HAVE NO OR
ONLY SPORADIC ACT THAT THE TAP
WATER. AND ESSENTIAL SERVICES
CRITICAL TO HELP SANITATION AND
CHILD DEVELOPMENT. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS LAURA FEINSTEIN ON
THE PHONE. YES I'M HERE YES
PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON TO
THE CHAIR COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
LAURA FEINSTEIN AND THE
pPOLICY DIRECTOR AT HER PUBLIC
POLICY ORGANIZATION IN THE BAY
AREA. AND YOU KNOW SAFE
DRINKING WATER IS ONE OF THE
MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO PROMOTE PUBLIC HEALTH AND AS
YOU HEARD FROM SENATOR DODD ONE
POINT SIX MILLION HOUSEHOLDS
HAVE FALLEN BEHIND ON THEIR
WATER BILLS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. UNDER CURRENT POLICY
MANY OF THESE CUSTOMERS WILL
LOSE ACCESS TO WATER THE SHOCK
MORATORIUM IS LIFTED WE NEED TO
ACT NOW TO AVERT AN EPIDEMIC OF
WATER SHUT OFF AMONG LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. A RARE IS MANAGED
PLAN HAVE BEEN USED WITH GREAT
SUCCESS BY UTILITIES AND OTHER
STATE THEY OFFER A BALANCED
APPROACH TO HANDLING CUSTOMER
UTILITY THAT. INTERMARRIAGE
MANAGEMENT PLAN DOES NOT FORGET
THAT UNCONDITIONLLY RATHER FOR
QUALIFIED LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS
IT FORGIVE A PORTION OF THAT IN
EXCHANGE FOR ON TIME IN FULL
BILL PAYMENT. MANAGEMENT PLANS
WHEN TARGETED TO CUSTOMERS DO
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO REPAY
THEIR DEBTS ARE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE HOUSEHOLD IN
THE UTILITY. THE CUSTOMER VOICE
TO SHUT OFF AND THE UTILITY
RETAIN A PAYING CUSTOMER.
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES MUST MEET
MANY FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS THE
BLL THEIR MISSION OF
DELIVERING SAFE WATER BUT THERE
IS ONLY ONE ESSENTIAL PART OF
THAT MISSION PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE TO CALIFORNIANS WHO
CANNOT AFFORD THEIR WATER BILL
THAT UTILITIES CANNOT PAY FOR
OUT OF THE RACE CARE REVENUE.
THIS BILL ASK AGENCIES TO TAKE
REASONABLE STEPS OF
PRIORITIZING USING THEIR NON
RATE PAIR REVENUE FOR URGENT.
HELPING THEIR CUSTOMERS IN A
TIME OF CRISIS. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE COMMITTEE FOR AND I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL GO MOVE NOT A SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TO THREE
THERE ARE NO- SPEAKERS IN THE
GALLERY OR IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SO MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO TO THREE.
AND WE ASK THEM TO LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THEIR MENU MEASURE ON THIS
MEASURE. AND- BUT I SUSPECT
SERVICE CALENDAR SPANIEN BUT
THE MOST KILOMETERS FOR COMMON
THIRTY FOUR FIVE ORDER CONTRA
NORM BUT IT SYSTEM THAT FEELS
COULD NOT ORGANISE ASEAN. HE-
QUARLESS WHO OR STEW A AN
ESTIMATE. DOES BE DEPRESSED. A
MODERATOR QUEUE THE SPEAKERS AT.
I'M SORRY YOUR MEDICARE THE END
SUPPORT FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO TO THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NET COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO. LINE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT YOUR MY
KIDS UP. BY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS OPEN PLEASE
CHECK FORME. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HI NATALIE REGARDING-
HAPPENED N SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT BIG. BLIND FORTY THREE
YOUR MIKE AT THE- GOOD EVENING
CHAIRED HUESO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF CERTIFICATES
ENERGY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD EVENING SURE NUMBERS
CHENEY GO ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT VICAR. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN YOUR MIKE AT THE- WHAT
THE AMERICAN CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. BLIND
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR YOUR
MIKE AT THE. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THAT AGAIN OF FRENCH CENTRAL IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB TWO TO TWO
AND TWO TO THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO YOUR MY KIDS
UP. GOOD EVENING CAITLYN COLUSA
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA COULD
KEEP RELIANCE INCLUDING TEN
INDIVIDUAL WATERKEEPER
ORGANIZATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN YOUR MIKE
AT THE. LINDA ESCALANTE THAT
NRDC IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. FILE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR YEAR MIKE IS
UP. ONE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
YOUR MY KIDS OPEN. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. SO WE ARE
CONFIRMING DOLLARS TO INCLUDE
WATER ACTIONS BECAUSE OF SB TWO
TO THREE AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE MOMENT TO WORKING GROUP'S.
SIGNIFICANT ACTION BY MICHAEL
JOHNSON CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE NETWORK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
SPEAKER. LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THEN YOU BRING IT
ALSO COMMUNITY WATER CENTER CAN
FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. THE LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN RODRIGUEZ
AT UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER HE PLAYED
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HELLO CAN TO GET
THE ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER
ALONG POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
AT THE TWO TO THREE. THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER. LINE NINETY
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. WOULD YOU
FROM THE BOTTOM WITH COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB TWO TWO TWO ALONGSIDE
WITH PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LA POLICY LINK
AND HERE CLICK UP ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE
NINETY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. LINE NINETY NINE YOUR
MIKE IT'S OPEN. THE NEXT BLIND
ONE HUNDRED. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY NINE YOUR MY KIDS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING SIR MEMBERS
BENJAMIN TRYING WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT
COMING THROUGH IT'LL JUST BE
ONE MOMENT WHILE I WHILE WE
GIVE THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER.
END OF LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE YOU'RE MY KIDDO. HI
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION A CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO OTHER SPEAKERS
AT THE TIME OKAY WE'LL BRING
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE HERE.
AND THE CHIEF OF THE- THE.
SENATOR DODD MENTIONED HE
ACCEPTS THE AMENDMENTS SO IF
THERE ARE ANY COMMENTS AT ALL.
OCEAN WOULD BE TO PASS
AMENDMENTS THE FIRST AMEND IT
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY CENTER
DOT I WOULD LOVE TO END THIS
CONVERSATION RIGHT HERE JUST
TAKE A VOTE BUT I BELIEVE WE
NEED OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL OH
I'M SORRY WE DO HAVE OPPOSITION
THAT'S RIGHT YES- AND WE HAVE A
LEAD WE HAVE LEAD OPPOSITION WE
JUST WRAPPED UP THE SUPPORT
SORRY ABOUT THAT- WILL GO TO
CHRIS ANDERSON. OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES SORRY MR ANDERSON ARE
YOU THERE. YES I'M HERE GOOD
EVENING MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU THAT SENATOR DOT
AS WELL- CHRIS ANDERSON ON THE
APPLICATION CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES ONE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- AS A
SENATOR NOTED WATER AGENCIES ON
THEIR CUSTOMERS BOB INSPIRED
FROM THE- ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS
BROUGHT ON BY THE PANDEMIC. AND
APPLE MEMBERS HAVE WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH THEIR
CUSTOMERS. BETTER FORMED BEHIND
ON THEIR BILLS BEFORE AND SINCE
THE PAN THAT. IN BEGAN- ALL
PARTIES ENGAGED IN THAT THEY'LL
WANT TO FIND WAYS TO HELP THOSE
IN NEED BY. SPT TWO THREE IS
NOT THE ANSWER THERE ARE TWO
PRIMARY REASONS FOR OUR
POSITION TODAY. THE BILL WOULD
PUT THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
MIDDLE OF LOCAL WATER
MANAGEMENT FUNDING DECISIONS
BUT REQUIRING PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES TO PRIORITIZE. NON
RATE REVENUE FOR FORGIVENESS OF
CUSTOMER THAT. WATER AGENCIES
UTILIZE NINE RATE REVENUE FOR
VARIETY OF PURPOSES INCLUDING
SAFE DRINKING WATER PROJECTS
REPAIRS AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND MORE- WATER AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN RELIED ON THESE FUNDS TO
ADDRESS REVENUE LOST DURING THE
PANDEMIC. IN PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES ARE IN THE BEST
POSITION TO JUDGE HOW THEIR
DOLLARS ARE SPENT. YEAH SB TWO
TO THREE WHICH STRIPPED THIS
RESPONSIBILITY FROM LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND FORCE
AGENCIES TO SPEND CERTAIN PLANS
IN ONE WAY REGARDLESS OF THE
NEED FOR THE WATER AGENCY.
WHICH WOULD MEAN UNDERFUNDING
OTHER CRITICAL NEEDS AND
POTENTIALLY LEAD TO HIGHER
WATER. RATES TO MAKE UP FOR
THIS LOSS REVENUE. SB TWO TO
THREE WAY ALL HAS REWRITE THE
STATE'S NEW RESIDENTIAL WATER
SERVICE SHUT OFF LAW WORK
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT LAW HAS
EVEN OCCURRED WATER AGENCIES
WERE REQUIRED TO BEGIN
IMPLEMENTING. SB NINE NINE
EIGHT IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
BUT WITH THE PANDEMIC IN THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
PLACING A MORATORIUM ON SHUT
OFF. SB NINE NINE EIGHT HAS NOT
EVEN BEEN FULLY IMPLEMENTED.
THIS KIND OF SENSITIVE REWRITE
OF THE NEW LARGE PREMATURE
STATE SHOULD GIVE WATER
AGENCIES AN OPPORTUNITY
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED SB
NINE NINE EIGHT. AND IN A SENSE
IT'S IMPACTS ON RESIDENTIAL
SHUTOFFS ONE STATE AND
BAILABLE. JUST WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFFER THERE
ANALYSIS MECHANICS THAT WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THE BILL
PLEASE REASON MORE OP WHICH
BACKED THE REQUEST YOUR NOBEL.
AND HAPPY. ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU NO SPEAKER
ENOUGH IN THE NOW IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WILL GO TO SPEAKERS. IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES-
MODERATOR PLEASE SECU SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO TO
THREE. FOUR COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO TO
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE. THEN
ZERO COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AN OUTLINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. HELLO
GALLAGHER WITH THE SAN JUAN
WATER DISTRICT OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. NEXT PICKER. A LINE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY YOUR MIKE
ABOUT. MISTER KAREN SENATORS
ANTHONY MOLINA ON BEHALF OF
MESA WATER DISTRICT AND A
TWELVE METRE THESE DISTRICTS AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER. LINE FORTY FIVE
HERE MY KIDS UP. HI THIS IS
MEGAN COLLETT YEAH WITH RANCHO
CALIFORNIA WATER DISTRICT AND
WE ARE BOTH A LOT OF MEN THAT.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. BLIND
ONE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE YOUR
MIKE IS THAT. WHERE ARE YOU
LOCATED ON BEHALF OF ONE OF OUR
WATER DISTRICT AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER. THE LINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY NINE YOUR MIKE AT
THE. RECEIVERS FOR THE MEDICAL
WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
THEY'RE OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND
PRINT THANK YOU. THANKS BAKER.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
RICKY ONE JUMP THE MOST
CRITICAL SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
CONCERNS ADDITION ON BOTH SB
TWO TWO TWO SB TWO TO THREE OF
OUTLINED IN THEIR LETTER AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS. ISSUE
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. THE LINE
SIXTY ONE YOUR MY KIDS UP. ONE
SIXTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
THANK YOU ARE CARE MEMBERS CAMP
IN THE TOWN HALL WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OUTLINED WITH AQUA
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT YOUR MY
KIDS UP. LINE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP AT.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
YOUR MY KIDS UP WITH FRIENDS. I
AND DINNER BUFFET WITH A
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
DISTRIBUTION WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AND
APPRECIATE WORKIN WITH THE
SPONSORS NOT AUTHORS TO RESOLVE
OUR CONCERNS AND THANK YOU FOR
THE COMMITTEE AND NOW WITH THIS
WELL. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY THREE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS BEST A LOT
THOUGH ON BEHALF OF THE
CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
WHERE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
INTO LINE WITH AQUA THANK YOU.
NEXT PICKER. BLIND SIXTY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. LINE
SIXTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD UP.
BLIND EIGHTY FOUR YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. BLIND EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR MY KIDS UP. THANK YOU
HANNAH DAVIDSON ON BEHALF OF
THE HIDDEN VALLEY LAKE
COMMUNITY SERVICES DISTRICT WE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
RANGE AGENCIES AND WE OPPOSE.
NEXT PICKER. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. I BELIEVE YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ONE FOR ALL THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THE SENATOR HAS
STAFF AND SPONSORS THAT. HAVE
BY UNDERTAKEN TO DATE AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO ON GOING DIALOGUE
CONSIDERATION ABOUT ENDING
ISSUES ARE BURKE- WE MUST
REMAIN OPPOSED WAS AMENDED AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
YOU'RE MY KIDDO. GOOD EVENING
BRIAN AND JACK WHEN WITH THE
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY WITHIN
OPPOSE THEM UP. THIS THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER. LINE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
ACTUALLY WALK AROUND THE HOUSE
AS A LEAVING HE NEED A COUPLE
WATER DISTRICT AND PADRE DAM
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
ALIGNING OUR POSITION AND
COMMENTS. AT AGE TWENTY AND U.
TWENTY THREE YEAH. THANK NEXT
BAKER. THE LINE SIXTY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. LINE
SIXTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH I GETS
US TO THE END OF PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL COME BACK TO THE FLOOR-
WILL TAKE CENTRE MEN DID YOU
WANT TO MAKE. MAKE A COMMENT. I
DID THANK YOU- I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA- FOR.
AFTER PUTTING THIS BILL I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY-
AND THE APPROACHES OUTLINED AS
FAR AS EMPHASIZING ARREARS
MANAGEMENT SOUNDS REASONABLE TO
ME I'M I DON'T PRETEND TO BE AN
EXPERT IN THIS AREA AND I DO
DEFERRED TO THE EXPERTISE. OF
MY COLLEAGUES FROM NAPA IN
WATER DELIVERY SINCE HE'S
ACTUALLY DONE IT- BUT I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS I JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS HI JUST OVER A YEAR AGO
OF COURSE SENATE. GOVERNOR KNEW
SOME- SIGNED HIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER ESTABLISHING A MORATORIUM
ON WATER SHUTOFFS AND- I THINK
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY THE RIGHT
THING TO DO IS WE HAD AN ECHO
OF IN. WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT
AND WE NEED TO PROTECT PEOPLE'S
ACCESS TO THAT. I GUESS MY
CONCERN IS WHETHER WE'RE
ADEQUATELY CONSIDERING THE
SOLVENCY FISCAL HEALTH OF OUR
WATER DISTRICTS- AS WE HEAD
INTO THESE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES-
I MET WITH A NUMBER OF-
CONSTITUENTS- RELATED THE WATER
INDUSTRY WATER DELIVERY EARLIER
THIS WEEK IN. ODD EARLIER DAY
MET WITH MY LOCAL WATER
DISTRICT- THERE CARRYING A BAD
DEBT RIGHT NOW ABOUT THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
DURING NORMAL TIMES THAT'S
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO THIS IS AN INCREASE
OF. ABOUT ALMOST 2000% OVER
THEIR NORMAL BAD DEBT LOAD AND
I ASSUME THIS IS A MICROCOSM.
OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING ACROSS THE
STATE. THIS IS AN ON. TIME FOR
WATER THIS BE. THE MORE- PROP.
TO EIGHTEEN AND US CENTER DOGS
RECENT BILL- AND SO I THINK
WHAT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL DO SEEM REASONABLE ON
THEIR FACE- I DO HAVE CONCERNS
IT'S ABOUT. ADDING ON TO SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE
ALREADY FACING SO. I AM GOING
TO VOTE TO MOVE THIS BILL OUT
OF COMMITTEE. TODAY BUT I DO.
WANT TO STATE THAT THAT'S BASED
ON. MINE THAT IT DOT IS WHO IS
COMMITTED TO WORK WITH THE
UPPER. TO HELP CONTINUE TO TAKE
THOSE. IN ACCOUNT. BOB I JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS THESE FOR THE
RECORD THANK YOU MR JEFF. OKAY
THANK YOU- ANYONE ELSE SO I'M
ASKING FOR A MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ANYBODY.
MOVE THE CENTER MEN VERY WELL
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH-
CENTER DODGE ONE MCKINNEY
CLOSING COMMENTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK THROUGHOUT THE- THANK YOU
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
TWO TO THREE BY SENATOR DODD
DID PASS A AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. WHAT'S SO. BY WESSEL
HI DOLLY. BAKER HI BAKER I
REGIS. BRADFORD ALL RIGHT
BRADFORD I DON I DODD HI.
EGGMAN RIGHT BETTER EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI. BRO.
HERTZBERG HI. HERTZBERG HI
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE I MAN HI MAN I
RUBIO. STERN STERN AYE STERN
AYE. SURE THAT'S TEN AS. K.
WILL KEEP THE ROLE BUT FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND WE'LL MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AS
BEFORE TWENTY THREE- CENTER
CERN STERN YOU CAN PERCENT.
FROM YOUR DESK. BUT UN ENERGY
RENEWABLE AND ZERO COMMA CARMEN
RESEARCH HAS SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- MEMBERS
FIRST I WANT TO START OFF BY
THANKING YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
ALL THE WORK ON A AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL. AND ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON WITH YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF- THERE. SEVERAL
MEMBERS SUGGESTED THE ANALYSIS
AND THEN. THERE'S ONE NEW PIECE
THAT I KNOW OUR STAFFS HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON. RECENTLY
DEALING WITH THE INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANS AND RESOURCE
ADEQUACY- SO WE'RE WILLING TO
ACCEPT ALL THOSE AMENDMENTS.
AND WITH THAT. THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO. ACCELERATE AND
IMPROVE THE THINKING AT THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION S
THEY APPROACH SB ONE HUNDRED SO
THAT THEY- THEY LOOK AT THE
OUTAGES WE'VE HAD IN HE PAST
FEW YEARS- AS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF REACHING OUR SB
ONE HUNDRED GOALS- LOOKING AT
THE NEED TO HAVE. THE ABILITY
TO GET THE GREED THROUGH A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR PERIOD OF
TIME. LOOKING AT ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES FOR BASELOAD LIKE-
EMERGING EFFORTS IN GEOTHERMAL
OFFICER WE WIN GREEN
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN LONG
DURATION ENERGY STORAGE MULTI
DAY ENERGY STORAGE AND OTHER
RESOURCES IDENTIFIED IN A
RECENT SB ONE HUNDRED REPORT.
WE BELIEVE THAT QUICKLY AND
COST EFFECTIVELY DEPLOYING
THESE ANOTHER FIRM BASELOAD
RESOURCES WILL IMPROVE
RELIABILITY AND RESILIENCY AND
THAT WE WILL REBUILD OUR GREED
DIFFERENTLY AND HOW TEXAS'S
INSISTED ON BUILDING THEY'RE
GREAT I THINK THERE'S A BETTER
WAY AND IT'S THE CALIFORNIA
WAY- THIS BILL HOPEFULLY
BRIDGES A DISCONNECT BETWEEN
THE RECENT SB ONE HUNDRED
REPORT THE SCOPING PLAN IN THE-
INTEGRATED ENERGY POLICY REPORT
AS WELL AS THE- I. R. P.
PROCESS IT P. YOU SEE. HEALTH
WE GET ALL THESE AGENCIES ON
THE ONE THE SAME PAGE- AND
PUSHING FOR A TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TIME FRAME FOR. THE MID TERM
RELIABILITY SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
OUR LIGHTS ON AND HOPEFULLY OF
CLEAN AIR AND PURSUE CLIMATE
JUSTICE IS A STATE. HAVE TO GET
INTO MORE DETAIL WITH MEMBERS I
KNOW IT'S A LATE HOUR HERE SO.
I'LL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR FOLKS
AYE VOTE AND- INHABITED ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS I HAVE TODAY HERE
ARE BILL SPONSOR V. JOHN WHITE
WITH THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN
AS WELL AS DANTE JACOBSON WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. OKAY WE
ALSO HAVE ON A LEAD OPPOSITION
SPEAKER FOLLOWING WHEN WE GET
TO OPPOSITION WILL BEGIN WITH
THE SUPPORT. WE FOR SAVAGE ON
WHY AND THEN THE. DAY NOT J.
JACOBSON FOLLOW WHEN. SO AS A
MISTER WHY OF LINE. THANK YOU
MISS CHAIRMAN I'M HERE. YES
PLEASE PROCEED INTO HEARING YES
WE CAN WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JOHN WHITE
WITH A QUICK CAR CAMPAIGN-
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG BEEN A
LEADER ON CLEAN ENERGY CLIMATE
POLICY MOST RECENTLY
EXEMPLIFIEDBY THE PASSAGE OF
THIS THE ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT CHANGED HOWEVER WITH THE
CONSEQUENCE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
MANIFESTING ITSELF THROUGH MORE
FREQUENT INTENSE WILDFIRES
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS SUCH AS
WE SAW LAST SUMMER CRITTER
LIABILITIES BECOME A CRITICAL
ISSUE. SB FOUR TWENTY TRUE
ENSURE THE GRID CAN
SIMULTANEOUSLY ADAPT TO AND
MAINTAIN RESERVES AGAINST
EFFECTIVE CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
SUCCESSFULLY MOVING AWAY FROM
FOSSIL FUELS. TO ACCOMPLISH TO
COMPLEMENT A GOLD THE STATE
NEEDS A DIVERSE PORTFOLIO OF
RENEWABLE AND ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES AND THE CHAIRMAN OVER
MEMBERSHIPS EFFORTS TO. PROMOTE
THE IDEA OF A BALANCED
PORTFOLIO WITH THE GEOTHERMAL
PROPOSAL SEVERAL YEARS AGO
WHICH WE REALLY WISH HAD PASSED
BECAUSE COULD USE THOSE
RESOURCES LAST SUMMER- WHAT WE
WANT TO SEE IS AN OPENING UP OF
THE STATE ENERGY AGENCIES
PLANNING PROCESSES TO. IDENTIFY
AND EVALUATE THE PERFORMANCE OF
THESE ODD NEW RESOURCES THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN CONSIDERED IN
RECENT MODELING BY THE PCS
CLOTHING OFFSHORE WIND
GEOTHERMAL. LONG DURATION
STORAGE- AND GREEN ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN- WITH THAT- DIRECTING
AGENCIES TO PURSUE
OPPORTUNITIES TO LOWER REPAIR
COSTS YOUR EXISTING AND
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES. AND
INCENTIVIZE INVOLVEMENT OF
THESE RESOURCES WILL HELP US
ACHIEVE OUR ECONOMIES OF SCALE
AND BRING DOWN COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH MEETING THE STATE'S CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AND
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU DANA
JACOB. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR WHY DO YOU NEED IN
YOUR IN THE CAR IN. STRONG
SERVE AS FOUR TWENTY THREE.
FROM WE BELIEVE THE COURT THREE
AN IMPORTANT STEP IN HELPING
THE STATE REACH ITS GOAL OF A
100% OR 1100% CLEAN ENERGY GOAL
IS DESIGNED TO FACILITATE THE
ADOPTION OF A DIVERSE SET OF
CLEAN ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES THE
CURRENT MODELING THAT THE CPUC
HAS CONSTRAINED AND HAS LIMITED
THE EVALUATION MANY OF THESE
KEY TECHNOLOGIES WHICH THE
SENATOR. AND MISTER WHITE HAVE
ALREADY SAID SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE RESPONSE TO THIS
CHALLENGE BY ENSURING THAT SUCH
SUCH TECHNOLOGIES ARE PROPERLY
EVALUATED MODELED AND THAT THE
VALUE OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES TO
OUR ELECTRICITY SYSTEM OR
APPROPRIATELY CONSIDERED. THE
RECENT CNC SB ONE HUNDRED
REPORT NOTED THAT ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS IS NEEDED TO EVALUATE
WHETHER THE PROJECT PORTFOLIOS
WILL MEET JUSTIN RELIABILITY
REQUIREMENTS WHILE CONTINUING
TO ASSESS RESOURCES. AND
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABILITY. MY
COMMON SHORT JUST BY SAYING
THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE. OF
HER GOING TO MEET OUR SB
HUNDRED. WE SUPPORT AND
KHORCHIN ARE BOTH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THEIR NO
SPEAKERS SUPPORT. IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE OR IN THE GALLERY SO
WILL GO DIRECTLY TO THE LINES A
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR TWO THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOUR TWO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO AND A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
ONE YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
MENTIONED FOR A MONSTER WITH
THE QUALITY CENTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. THE WIND OF ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR MIKE IT'S
OPEN. WE NEED TO STICK WITH THE
WHITE MAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
STORM ENERGY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER MORE
SPEAKERS. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO MORE SPEAKERS AT THE
TIME OKAY WE HAVE- A SPEAKER A
LEAD OPPOSITION SPEAKER ANTHONY
SAMPSON- IS MISTER SAMPSON
ONLINE. YES I'M HERE MISTER YES
SIR PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU READY.
BREAKWALL THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
DANTE PHANTOM ADVANCED AND
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POWER AUTHORITY IN RESPECT
BOUGHT THE DISH AND THE FORD AT
THE FOUR TWENTY THREE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ON THE
MEASURE AND- THUNDERSTORMS
WILLINGNESS. TO TAKE THE KIDS
SOME OF THE THAT THE COMMITTEE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS- FROM THE
SENATORS PRESENTATION AT I IT'S
NOT EXACTLY CLEAR WHICH
AMENDMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
TAKEN BY. LOOKING AT THE
WORKING OFF. OF THE KIDNEY
COMMITTEE AND ALEX THAT. THE
PROBE WE VERY MUCH INTO OF
REMOVING. THE REFERENCE TO THE
P. O. UNITS I. R. PEAS. AND
ALSO VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
STRIKING A LANGUAGE TO THE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE R. H. A
SECTION OF THE BILL- REMAINING
UPPER FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THIS
SECTION FOR THE BILL AND- THAT
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS PROPOSES.
THAT THE BILL BE AMENDED TO
ALLOW THE CDC TO MAKE
PROCUREMENT RECOMMENDATIONS TO
PETE PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES
REGARDING GROWING RENEWABLE AND
ZERO CARBON RESOURCES. WHILE
THIS APPROACH IS CERTAINLY FAR
PREFERABLE THAN ALLOWING EASY
TO MAKE PROCUREMENT DECISIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE PIER USE. WE
STILL DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THAT
IS AN APPROPRIATE ROLE FOR THE
CVC APPEAR USE THROUGH THE
LOCAL PROCUREMENT DECISION
MAKING PROCESS TO PRODUCE WELL
BALANCED AND DIVERSE PORTFOLIOS
OF GROWING RENEWABLE. AND ZERO
CARBON RESOURCES ALL THE WHILE
KEEPING RATES AFFORDABLE FOR
THE REPAIRS IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES. ELECTIVELY THE PO
USE THAT THOUSANDS OF MEGAWATTS
THE PLAN PROCUREMENT FOR A
DIVERSE ARRAY OF RESOURCES THAT
MEET SHORT MEDIUM AND LONG TERM
RELIABILITY NEEDS. OVER THE
LONG TERM AND INDEED. THESE
INCLUDE SOME OF THE VERY
RESOURCES SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL. FIFTY THREE ON THE OTHER
HAND IS NOT IS NOT IN THE
PROCUREMENT BUSINESS. AT THE
STATE AND ENTITY WE DO NOT
BELIEVE. THAT THEY ARE WELL
POSITIONED TO RECOMMEND WHAT
PROCUREMENT DECISIONS MAKE THE
MOST SENSE WITHIN THE
JURISDICTIONS OF THE FORTY PLUS
PO USED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE PROCUREMENT NEEDS APPEAR
USE DIFFER DEPENDING ON THAT
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES RESOURCE
NEEDS AMONG OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS. WHICH IS WHY
THE PO USED THROUGH THE
OVERSIGHT OF THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNING BODIES THAT THAT
DECISION TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS. THANKS AGAIN- MISTER
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
SENATOR STERNWHEELER LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
MOVING FORWARD. SHE FOR A
WEALTH YOU- WILL JUST. AND
OPPOSITE- MODERATE. THERE ARE.
SPEAKERS AN OPPOSITE THE GAL
NINE AND GROUP ONE TWELVE. SO
MODERATOR FOR COULD YOU PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION ON ON
THE LINES. FOR COMMON IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN
ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WHILE WE GIVE OUT THEIR LINE
NUMBERS. AND WHILE WE'RE
WAITING I ASK ALL THOSE- MAKING
THEIR COMMENTS TO LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY. TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION OF THE POSITION ON
THIS MEASURE AS BEFORE TWO
THREE. MODERATOR PLEASE TO THE
FUTURE THE FIRST SPEAKER. FIFTY
ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE. AND
LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN WHICH CHAIRED.
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MISTER
SAMPSON FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY. NEXT BIGGER. IN LINE
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. I HAVE A QUOTE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION AND I'D
LIKE TO REMIND MY COMMENTS WITH
THAT OF MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
INSTANT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYMORE SPEAKERS. WE HAVE ONE
MORE COMING THROUGH IT ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GIVE
THEM THEIR LINEUP. AND A LINE
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY CONSULTANT. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS CAPPING RANCH-
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE FOR PLUG IN AMERICA. THE
AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
OKAY WILL COME NOT TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS. AND SO
THERE WERE. AMENDMENTS MADE TO
THIS BILL- COPIES WERE MADE
THERE ARE STILL ONE AMENDMENT.
THAT WILL BE ADDED IN THE
SUBSEQUENT COMMITTEE SO OTHERS
CAN BE AMENDMENT TO IN ONE OF
THE AMENDMENTS AND- THAT
COMPLICATES. MATTERS ON THIS
BILL A LITTLE BIT BUT WE'VE
AGREED TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
TO TO WORK ON ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS SO- FAR OUR PROPOSAL
IS- TO PASS THIS. AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY WHERE THE
LAST AMENDMENT. WOULD BE MADE.
SO- MAYBE- CENTER STERN COULD
YOU SPEAK TO THE I MEAN YOU
ALREADY DID IN YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS BUT I WANT TO WORK- RE
YOU KNOW. RICKREDESCRIBED
AGAIN THE COMMITTEE THE I MET
FOR WORKING OUT GREAT YEAH YEAH
I I'M I APOLOGIZE ALSO TO THE
OPPOSITION I SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CLEAR I DIDN'T KNOW HOW MUCH
DETAIL THE PUT IN MY OPENING
BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR TO ALL THE
MEMBERS WE ARE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE P. O. USE
THE PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES OF
ASK FOR IN TERMS OF- STRIKING
V. AND THE REFERENCE TO TWO
PEOPLE USE I. R.PEAS. AND TO
ALLOW THE C. C. TERM MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT NOT TO
REQUIRE ANY PROCUREMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE PO YOU SO WE
HEARD THAT LOUD AND CLEAR
THAT'S ON PAGE SIX OF YOUR
ANALYSIS- ALSO ON PAGE SIX
URINALYSIS IS A REFERENCE TO
THE ARE A STANDARD- WE ARE
STRIKING LANGUAGE PROPOSING
CHANGES TO THE ARE A STANDARD-
WE ARE. ALSO- YEP BEING CLEAR
NOT. AND THEN REMOVING
REFERENCE TO THE PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES INTEGRATEDRESOURCE
PLAN SAYS HAS ALSO SUGGESTED IN
THE ANALYSIS THE ADDITIONAL
WORK THAT THE CHAIR REFERENCES.
TO ADD THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANS FOR
I. O. U.'S INCLUDE RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS MULTI DAY EXTREME OR A
TYPICAL WEATHER EVENTS THAT
LOWER RENEWABLE ENERGY OUTPUT
IN A CURRENT LEASES FREQUENTLY.
FREQUENTLY AS ONCE IN TEN YEARS
AND FOR THE MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC THAT'S THE ACTUAL
LANGUAGE OF THE AMENDMENT. AND
THAT WILL IS IT BEING ADDED- IN
THIS COMMITTEE SO. BURKE PRETTY
MUCH THOSE FOR AMENDMENTS WERE
OR ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS
AMENDMENT UNLESS- ANYBODY NEEDS
ANY CLARIFICATION I CAN CLARIFY-
CENTER BAKER DID YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. YES SUCH WHEN
ASSEMBLY HAPPY TO SEE THE
AUTHORS FOCUS ON THE NEED FOR
MORE CLEAN FROM POWER IN THIS
BILL. AS WE SAID A PATH TOWARDS
UNDER SECRETARY G. PUTTING FROM
RESOURCES LIKE LONG DURATION
STORAGE OR- POWER PLANTS USING
RENEWABLE FUELS. WILL BE
CRITICAL TO MANAGING THE GRID
DURING EXTENDED PERIODS OF LOW
SOLAR AND THE WIND PRODUCTION.
TO VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. VERY COMPLEMENTARY TO MY
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN CLEAN ENERGY.
STANDARD BILL WHICH WILL BE
DISCUSSING. IN THE COMMITTEE IN
A FEW WEEKS THANKS VERY MUCH TO
THE AUTHOR. IS THAT A MOTION.
SURE I WOULD MOTION OKAY THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS. RAISE
YOUR HAND IF YOU DO. OKAY THEN
WE'LL MOVE FORWARD BUT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OUT BEFORE WE DO
SAYS SIR DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS OF NO THANKS
SO MUCH CORRECT INSTRUMENT-
STOCK CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB FOUR TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR STERN DO PASSED AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. FLESSEL
BY WHISTLE HI DOLLY. HELLO
DOLLY GNOME BAKER. HI BAKER I
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD. DODD ALL
RIGHT DODD HI. EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
I GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ HI. HELLO.
IN IS A NO GRAVANO. HERTZBERG I
HERTZBERG BY. MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE
HI. MAN BY BERMAN I RUBIO.
STERN STERN AYE STERN HI. SURE
THAT'S NINE AS INTERNALS OKAY
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT FOR SB FIVE EIGHT NINE
I'M THE PRESENTER SO WHAT I'M
GONNA DO IS A- PASSED THE GAVEL
OVER TO- MY VICE CAIR- CENTER
DOLLY. SENATE HUESO PRESENTING
SB FIVE EIGHT NINE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY
PLEASURE TO PRESENT SB FIVE
EIGHT NINE THIS IS A BILL THAT
IS INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES REFLECT
THE NEED TO GROW IN STATE
ECONOMY. IN STATE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
WORKFORCE EQUITY THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO CONSULT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
IN THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. DURING THE CREATION
OF WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PRIORITIES FOR THE CDC'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. THE
BILL ALSO CLARIFIES A PROJECTS
DEVELOPING IN STATE RAW
MATERIALS AND SUPPLY CHAINS FOR
PARTS NEEDED FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING FROM THE CDC'S COMPLAIN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES A CC TO
CONSULT WITH THE CONSERVATION
CORPS SAID THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. BUT WHEN CREATING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
INVESTMENT STRATEGIES TO ENSURE
THAT EARLY STAGE OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES. ON AND
ARE INCLUDED- THIS BILL
SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO DEVELOP ALL
IN STATE SUPPLY OF RAW
MATERIALS AND COMPONENTS NEEDED
FOR A Z. EV'S. SERVICE BY
MAKING PROJECTS TO DEVELOP THE
SUPPLY CHANGE ELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING. FOR THE CDC'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM SB FIVE
EIGHTY NINE WILL ENSURE THAT AS
WEEK CELEBRATE INVESTMENTS IN
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION WE ALSO
GROW IN STATE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES PARTICULARLY
THOSE IN COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED FROM
THE GREEN ECONOMY- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. I HAVE A LEAD SUPPORT
SPEAKER- DEREK BENSON FROM
ENERGY SOURCE ONLINE THAT
WISHES TO ALSO- MAKE SOME
COMMENTS AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
HAVE. MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE Q. THE LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. SURE ONE GLUTEN.
PERCENT LOOKING FORWARD ERICA
PRATT BENTSEN CORRECT YES GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME HAS
THERE BEEN SOME SPEAKING. YES
WE CAN GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR GET A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DEREK BENSON I'M THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER FOR ENERGY
SOURCE MINERALS. THE ENERGY
SOURCE TEAM DEVELOPED AND NOW
OPERATES THE NEW GEOTHERMAL
FACILITY IN THE CITY. CURRENTLY
DEVELOPING THE FIRST EVER
PROJECT TO EXTRACT LITHIUM FROM
GEOTHERMAL BRINE. THE TEAM
EXTRACTION FROM GEOTHERMAL
BRINE IS NEW. OUR TECHNOLOGY
WILL ALLOW LITHIUM TO BE.
EXTRACTED FROM THE BRIAN THAT
THIS PRODUCT IS PART OF THE
GEOTHERMAL ENERGY PROCESS
BEFORE THAT IS DELIVERED BACK
INTO THE GROUND. IT IS THE MOST
SUSTAINABLE AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY METHOD FOR A MINING
LITHIUM BECAUSE THIS FACILITY
AND OTHERS THAT WILL LIKELY
FOLLOW IN THE SOUTH REGION ARE
FIRST GENERATION WE NEED. WE'RE
NEED- TURNING INTO AN ENTIRELY
NEW WORKFORCE FROM THE GROUND
UP WE HAVE ALREADY WRITTEN
BEGUN CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
DETERMINE HOW WE CAN DEVELOP
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND CLASSES.
IN THE BILL THIS NEW ACCOUNT
THAT WE NEED. WORKFORCE WILL BE
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THIS
INDUSTRY AND FOR THE REGION-
COUNTY IT'S CONSISTENTLY ONE OF
THE MOST DISADVANTAGED IN THE
COUNTRY AND THE JOBS. BY THESE
PROJECTS WILL BE VITAL FOR
COUNTY WITH AROUND TWENTY
PERCENT. UNEMPLOYMENT AND THIS
WAS EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
SO WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
SINCERE THANKS TO SENATOR HUESO
FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND
REFER. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NOW TESTIFY TESTIFY
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC I SEE
NOBODY IN THE- GALLERY ANYBODY
IN ONE TWELVE. SEEING NONE THEN
WE WILL GO TO THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE THOSE WISHING TO.
TESTIFIED SUPPORT MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. OR COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. FIVE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND I SHOW NO COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR MARI NOW
WILL GO INTO- WITNESS'S
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION TO HAVE
ANYONE. AS THE TESTIMONY I
DON'T BELIEVE WE DO IS THERE
ANY PUBLIC THEIR WISHES IS
EVERYBODY IN THE GALLERY NO
ROOM ONE TWELVE NO- ANYBODY IN
THE PUBLIC THAT WISHES TO
OPPOSE SB FIVE EIGHT NINE.
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE QUEUE. FOUR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. FIVE
EIGHT NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
TEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. UNDER THE ONE COMMENT
COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH THEIR LIFE FOR. IN LINE
FORTY THREE YOUR MIKE AT THE. I
HEARD OPPOSITION BUT I'M
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT- THIS IS
STEPHEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MODERATOR
PLEASE CHECK AGAIN IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW CLOSE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND BRING IT
BACK TO MEMBERS OTHER MEMBERS
THAT HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR SB
FIVE EIGHT NINE. WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THE BILL PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION. THAT SINGLE
MORE TESTIMONY OR QUESTIONS. WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT SB
FIVE EIGHTY NINE BY SENATOR
WESSEL DID PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION.
WESSEL BY WESSEL HI DOLLY HI
DOLLY HI BAKER. BY BAKER HI
BURGESS. BRADFORD BRADFORD I
DONE OKAY DODD HI EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN NINE GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ
HI GROSS. HI ZERO HI. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE
BY IN FIVE MAN HI RUBIO HI
RUBIO HI STERN HI STERN FINE.
THIRTEEN AS- CARE OKAY ARE THAT
WERE THERE ANY- ABSENT MEMBERS
ON THIS BILL. SENATOR BORDERS.
OKAY WE'LL KEEP THE OPEN IN
CASE HE RETURNS- WE'RE GOING
TO- GO TO- THE FILE NOW AND
OPEN THE ROLE ON ON- THE REST
OF THE BILL'S BEGINNING WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TWO
EIGHT CABALLERO- OF CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON THIS PAGE TWENTY EIGHT. SB
TWENTY EIGHT DID PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
HERTZBERG HI. HI MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE STERN. STERN HI
FORGES. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE CABALLERO. SB.
TWENTY EIGHT. CALL CALL AGAIN
HONESTY SB TWENTY EIGHT S. B.
TWENTY. MORE JUST AS A SIGN
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I'M SORRY
THAT'S FOURTEEN AS K. WILL
CLOSE A ROLAND ON ITEM NUMBER.
ONE CORRECT. THE LAKE WOULD
CLOSER OF. NUMBER TWO SB FIVE
FORTY SIX BY CENTER WILK. SB
FIVE FORTY SIX BY SENATOR WILK
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I STERN. STERN HI SURE
THAT'S FOURTEEN DAYS OKAY WE'LL
GET THE- WILL CLOSE ROLAND-
ITEM TO WILL GO TO ITEM THREE
SB SIX SIX TWO BY CENTER ARCH
ALETTA- CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SB SIX SIX TWO
BY SEVEN ARCHULETA DEPRESSES
AMENDED- AB. FORTIS. IS A NO
REGIS NO. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE MCGUIRE. STERN STERN I.
SURE THAT'S TEN AS AND THREE
MALES OKAY THE BILL IS OUT WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN THAT WANT TO
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS
BEFORE I CENTER GONZALEZ- CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SB FOUR BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
FORGES. GROW HERTZBERG. THIS IS
ALL. HERTZBERG HI MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE I STERN. HI STERN I.
SURE THAT'S ELEVEN AS ON ONE
NOW OKAY WILL CLOSE- ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. WILL MOVE WHICH
ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS P. TWO TWO
TWO BY SENATOR DODD CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SB TWO TWO TWO BY SENATOR DODD.
PORGES. NOW PORGES NO. GROW.
REQUIRE MCGUIRE I RUBIO. RUBIO
AYE STERN. STERN HI. SURE
THAT'S ELEVEN DAYS INTO THOSE
CABLE CLOSER ROLE ON ITEM
NUMBER FIVE WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ON ITEM SIX SB TWO TO THREE BY
SENATOR DODD CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SB TWO TO
THREE BY SENATOR DOT. DOLLY NO
DALI KNOWN. GORGEOUS. FOR HIS.
HELLO RUBIO. RUBIO I. THAT'S
ELEVEN DAYS IN ONE NOW. ONE S.
B. TWO TWO THREE YES HELLO OF
CULTURAL AND S. B. TWO TO THREE
ON ITEM NUMBER SIX OPEN UP NINE
I DON'T KNOW NUMBER SEVEN. SB
FOUR TWO THREE BY SENATOR STERN
PLEASE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SB FORTY THREE
BY SENATOR STERN TO PASS AS
AMENDED. SENATOR PORCHES
RESPECTFULLY NEW HOPE. SENATOR
BRIDGES RESPECTFULLY NO. ABSENT
A BRADFORD. SEVEN RUBIO. SEVEN
A RUBIO I. THAT'S TEN AS AND
THREE THOSE OKAY THE BILL
ITSELF WILL CLOSE ROLAND SAID-
ITEM SEVEN OPEN THE ROLE ON
ITEM EIGHT SB 589% OR WAS SO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SB FIVE EIGHTY NINE BY SENATOR
WESSEL DEPRESSED AND REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
SO THAT OUR BORDERS HI. TO THE
REPORTERS I HEAR THAT'S
FOURTEEN DAYS. OKAY THE BILL IS
OUT. WE WERE ALL CLOSE IN ROLE
IN ALL THE BILLS THANK YOU TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED PUBLIC TESTAMENTUM
TOOK TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US. AND WE WANT INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY THE OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU T EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION DURING
THESE DIFFICULT TIMES WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS.
IS NOW INJURED HAVE A GOOD
EVENING.